and elderly affairs committee
and i have to read the script
as chairman of the house health human
services and elderly affairs committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the coven 19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee meeting of the house
health human services and elderly
affairs committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to listen
contemporaries
and if necessary that's what it says
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
notice for this meeting
complies with
house rules
and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email
h c
s at
l e g
dot
state
nh dot
u s
in the event the public as a whole is
unable to access this meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
christina dayak committee researcher
will be the staff assisting us today
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by world cup votes
we will start the meeting by taking a
one of our members is away
and we are blessed to have charles
melvin
substituting for her
when each member states his or her
presence please also state whether there
is anyone else in the room with you
during this meeting and this is required
under the right to know law
would the clerk
thank you mr chairman i did not catch
the name of the person who is
substituting today
charles
melvin i sent you a text
oh okay thank you very much
okay um
representative marsh
i am president of the room
representative mcmahon
i am present
representative gay
representative cushman
and present in the room
representative folsom home alone
representative
uh melvin
representative king
here in the room
i just saw you there you are sorry about
that hit the wrong button uh i am in my
home office in wilton there are other
people in the house there's no one else
in the room
representative weber
uh present from concord and i am alone
in the house
representative mckay you're muted
i'll come back
um
representative snow stated that he will
be joining us in a little bit
okay representative conner
i'm alone in my
home study in freedom new hampshire my
wife's in the house but not in the room
representative soloway
i am at home in my office alone in lee
new hampshire thank you representative
cannon
[Music]
i'm home alone in my home in somersworth
new hampshire and there's no one else in
the room
representative nutter uppam
i'm here in nashua uh alone in the room
not alone in the house
representative shapiro
good morning i am
home in keene in my office
thank you representative woods
uh good morning i'm i'm at home and at
my home in beau in my study and i'm in
the house alone
representative merchant
i'm home
in claremont new hampshire in my house
and my wife are in the house
representative pearson
i am in the committee room
representative
gay has also arrived in the committee
room
um is
uh the only one that i don't have any
account for is representative nelson so
if someone sees him come online if you
there are builds
that come up from time to time
where people are deeply impassioned one
way and the other
and it's very much to the credit of this
committee
that when a very similar bill
came up
last year
we were free
to speak what we believe
and
we were also
highly courteous of
individuals
as we go into
this next bill
i'm trusting that it will continue this
spirit that was so evident last year
we can say what is our beliefs and why
but we can be very respectful of people
both with whom we are debating
and also that a bill may
have to do with
so with that in mind
i open
the hearing on house bill 295
relative to initiating amendments and
corrections to work records and i call
on our very own representative cannon
who is the prime sponsor of this film
thank you mr chair and fellow committee
members for the record my name is
representative jerry cannon
i represent stratford county district 18
as has been mentioned by the chair
you have seen versions of this bill in
the past
hb 295
is a bill identifying procedures for an
individual to correct their birth
records
it's updating statute rsa
5-c colon 87 roman numeral 5.
that
rsa
was enacted in 2005 and became effective
on january 4th
15 years ago
there's a problem that occurred back
then
part of the part the biggest problem was
the
form that was needed to help clerk the
court and the vital records office was
never created
that's one of the primary reasons for
this bill does not create the ability
for gender information to be corrected
or changed on a birth record
that ability
was defined in that rsa and enacted
and
enacted by our legislature and governor
back in 2005.
we are only requesting that procedures
be put in place
and update some of the things that we've
noted over the past for those
people on the line who are unfamiliar
with what rsa 5-c colon 87 roman numeral
5 says
it's essentially a single sentence
upon receipt of a certified copy of a
court order advising that such
individual born in the state of new
hampshire has had a sex change a new
birth record shall be prepared to
the missing part
to that rsa
is that
this is no information for what is
required by the court
or the clerk
i
in working with a number of people who
their information to be
updated
we've run into some serious problems and
very awkward for those people who have
applied
because every county and clerk's office
is different in the way they've
the um
if we go to section 5
in our rsas
that are focused on on vital records the
very first rsa
defined that
and any change to a birth record shall
be initiated with the clerk
of the town or city
our
our application our applicants
have gone to their town or city clerk to
they don't have a form there to fill out
to collect the information
that's required to help process the
information
and many times they'll get a blank stare
from the clerk
because
the clerk may not
know that that
that they can actually do this
and we've even had applicants turned
away from the clerk's office
because the clerk
essentially has told them well we can't
do this because there's no information
available for them
so the um
the applicant ends up going to
the
county court
to ask for a form
and a request to talk with the judge
there is no form
in the county
courts
to fill out but they can get some time
once you've seen once you go to the
judge
if some of the judges have had these
cases before and are very familiar with
what they require for information and
most of the times it's a simple letter
from
the doctor
the applicant has been saying it's
associated with the
their sex
change information
and for other judges it could be two or
three different visits
for them to require the additional
information and knowledge to make an
the form that should have been made
available should have been created back
in
the
challenges in general is that new
hampshire judges
don't have the medical knowledge to make
an informed decision
they are totally reliant on the
applicant providing information
and what we're seeing currently is that
some judges who have seen this
information
have processed these cases in the past
they see the doctor's letter and they
just
issue the court order
but it does require a court visit and
time and effort for the applicant and
the um
in the in the case of the the original
rsa
a
court order would be issued and a birth
certificate would be issued by the vital
records office
that birth record that was issued by
court order does not have a marginal
note on it
they are essentially replacing
the birth record
with a new birth record with no pointer
back to an original
what we are asking for with this request
is that
a new birth record be issued but it will
have a marginal note that points back to
the original
birth record
that's
on our vital record system
i will tell you many of the transgender
community is not happy with that
but
they can still go back to the court to
get a court order
and issue a birth record that does not
the um
challenge here is that it's whole
time-consuming effort
for the applicant
our courts and the clerk's office and it
i will reiterate the prime focus of this
bill
is not to change the intent of the
the intent of this bill
is about saving the state
in simple
in simple terms a birth record change
form needs to be created
that identifies all of the applicant's
personal information
needed by the vital records office
to make the changes
the form also needs a section to be
signed and notarized by one of the
applicants licensed medical
professionals
including
the flight the license number
attesting to the applicant's gender
status
it needs to have all this information
the physician the physician's
one thing to note
um
a person that's going through a sex
change works with
a therapist licensed therapist
psychologist
their personal care physician
endocrinologist
similar procedures have been going on in
20 states
the process reduces
the court workflow
and we have quite a workload
for it essentially overworked
there is no financial note attached to
we are not adding non-binary people to
this bill
i've been asked to include non-binary
people
i know the problems with that
it would cost a hundred thousand dollars
in software cost
to enact that
this has no financial note
the software
can already do what's being requested
and they are currently using it many
people have already
filed for their sex change and corrected
their birth certificates
i encourage you to vote
to pass on 295 house bill 295
to help save the state
county and clerk's offices
time and money
to process
birth record gender corrections
thank you and i will take questions
chair recognizes representative mckay
for questioning
thank you mr chairman my intention is
just to see if i'm getting through it at
this point
you are
thank you
the chair recognizes the clerk there's
only the folsom
thank you mr chairman um
thank you representative cannon for
bringing this forward you've actually
clarified quite a few things in my brain
already
um
do
people when people want to change
something else on their birth
certificate
do they have to jump through the same
hoops
as this
or what is their process if they're
changing a name or
a father's name or a mother's name or
whatever the forms already exist to do
that in the clerk's office
they don't have to go to the court it's
uh it's processed in the court office
and then sent to the vital records
office and it's taken care of a 10 for a
10 feet
um follow-up yes follow-up
um so basically you're just asking that
the same form
being created and maintained
for
the purposes of changing the gender
yes
yes the the only section i am requesting
that's in addition to the current forms
is to provide a section
for a physician to sign off and notarize
the form
it looks like shapiro for questions
am i right
thank you mr chairman and um thank you
representative cannon
you
said that currently
a problem is that the forum
doesn't exist or is inadequate
and i'm looking at the bill and i'm not
really seeing anything about the
creation
of a form
it
the form should have been
created back when the original rsa was
was um
created that i i don't know if there was
anything in that bill about the creation
that reform
um
the information being there is a section
that's that defines what's required for
a physician to sign and have attest to
the thing i i did not identify the
specifics of the of a form because we
there are already forms that do this we
we already have a form that contains
essentially the same information
that our dmv requires to change a gender
id on a on a driver's license the
federal government has a form to change
that information
on our passports
the nashua
city clerk had indicated that they could
create a form simply for for their
clerk's office and that form could be
used elsewhere
representative acton for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative spain for taking my
question
um
last year
when we went over this subject there was
some pushback as far as
not having
a marker that designated
that there was a change in the records
and that could possibly throw off
um physicians or statisticians because
um because there was no
indicator of a change in the birth
certificate is this
a
compromise to address those
issues
the um
it was identified by the
vital records office that if we changed
the if we
if we modified a birth record without a
court order they would include a
marginal record pointing back to the
original birth certificate in the
current version in the current rsa
when it is is issued by a court order
there is no marginal note and the birth
the original birth record does not have
to be maintained so in the case of the
concern that an original birth record
would be destroyed or made non-existent
this bill
actually confirms that that birth record
will still continue to exist on the
okay uh
i think it's one thing to go down to the
clerk's office and
change your car registration it's
obviously much more
personal situation um would would
rectifying the situation saved
so it must be rather embarrassing to
walk in there to have the
personal information then get a
i'm sorry i i couldn't make out
everything you said could you repeat
your question
basically
i'm acknowledging that what must be
rather humiliating to walk into
the office and have to get a run around
it's not like you're switching
registration place
um so
i will will
the passage of this bill rectify
the situation where people are being
humiliated during
an interaction with government
um
in some cases especially someone who is
has not been out in public for a long
time however
to have undergone the the changes to
their gender
the current requirement from the medical
field is that they be out in public and
living their life true to the gender
they identify with for at least a year
and physicians would like two or years
more
when i applied for
my gender
change information in massachusetts a
few years ago
i had been out in public for 15 years
so it was no issue for me
and for younger people
who get this information changed
and even
someone who's under the year age of 18
along with their parents
is in most cases these people are so
excited about getting this information
changed to make their life easier
primarily for themselves because a birth
certificate is rarely used
for
for other
um
other information changes
but a passport is one of those things
that could be required but
but now with the proper form
an individual can go get that changed
um
so
does it impact some people
yes um
i know that i was very concerned when i
was first
coming out as a transgender person
to have to tell someone that i was a
transgender individual
can be a very awkward situation
it's not anymore
i'm an elk person so but a lot of people
aren't
thank you for your question
representative
thank you mr chair um
i want to come back to the uh question
that representative shapiro asked and
delve a little deeper
um
first of all it's like who actually
prepares this form is it going to be
done by the town clerk of the state and
given that issue then do we need to
state that the clerk of each town shall
create such a form or do we need to
authorize rule making for the state to
develop this form i just want to make
sure that that doesn't fall through the
cracks another time
um good point
um first off i don't think it should be
done by
well
i know that we had a city clerk offered
to do this to create a form that could
be put online for all to use
i think we need to have something that's
approved by the state for use in all of
our clerk's offices
i'm not sure if it requires a rule to do
that or
if i should put uh amend this text to
include that as something that needs to
be done
and and
i'm not sure who to identify to do that
so
yeah it affects all the clerks so if
follow-up
i don't see gary i think we've lost the
uh oh no we lost him
yes yes we're working on getting it
turned back on i think they're frozen um
and i'll see what i can do well i'll
just assume he's going to give me
authority i i would think that we would
at least want to give it they can't hear
you they can't they can't hear you you
should wait
well i'll say this isn't more an answer
i think rule making authority for vital
records to do i did have a follow-up
question but i'll wait till we see
people's faces back
hey dennis oh
does do your ducks lay eggs
um
yes we gotta get about the egg delete
okay
i'll email you something later thanks
all right
representative snow
this is beth the clerk um if you could
unmute during this time and
tell me where you are i am now unmuted
and i should also say i was held up this
morning and i didn't get a chance to say
that i'm in i'm in my apartment in
manchester my wife is in the building
and i will be here i may have to leave
proportion because my second vaccination
shot is going to be administered here at
is is our assistant chair available
representative in the room
he's in the room
but we've lost the room is that correct
yeah apparently yeah and bill is on his
computer so he's not it's not the system
just an observation
i
cannot access
the session on my computer
i'm on my phone
and i'm going to assume that comcast
lines are down in my area
and i'm over a phone line
um so i and i'm going to assume that
there are other people on the committee
is that correct i will add that my i had
a power blip here in wilton that lasted
probably a second or two but it was
enough that my router had to reset
so i was gone from the meeting for
probably three or four minutes
um so yeah sometimes even a a momentary
power outage can lead to
um
so
my
oh okay
um
well i wonder oh
awesome that not none of the attendees
can see or hear what we're
right
yeah uh hey christina just a curiosity
are you are you in the room with them or
are you
remote
or not i'm actually remote so um okay
yeah that's because i just texted bill
marsh to find out what you know what's
going on i mean whether they just had a
power blip or whether they're totally
without power
he hasn't answered back yet
um so my understanding um just from
my colleagues is that um
the ethernet went down the building so
they'll have to bring it back up shortly
all right
why are we looking at amendments for
hb220
what was that joe you're muted now
all of a sudden i saw an amendment and i
assumed it was screen sharing but i
think what actually happened is that i
lost something and this was underneath
oh got it yeah i'll figure it out
you had me nervous
well we go back to the ducks back to
so
so i hear duck eggs make the best cakes
they're great for baking they have a
nice rich flavor to them
that's what i heard so
if you could ever spare two eggs i would
that is astounding only only in this
committee can you get such good
information
well i'm going to go get myself some
that would be virtual coffee
did anyone
did anyone else
dartmouth hitchcock
um
webinar yesterday morning
what was it on
agendas
okay i just didn't hear an answer so i
watch again you're unmuted
now
so how many of us are still on i i see i
gotta get my mirror out i see jeff
jeff is here yeah
jerry jerry's here
nobody else jerry can eric
yeah
oh yeah good all right
there's 14 of us
yeah but we're some of us have binked
off no
no there's 14 of us that are oh
i i believe you i'm sorry all right
oh my
the chair is asking the clerk to call
the roll our mics here in the room are
not working yet
i think the clerk went to get coffee i
but the clerk please call the rules just
to affirm everyone's back
okay i will do that uh representative
marsh i am president
representative mcmahon president
representative folsom here
representative
melvin
representative king
here
representative
representative weber
she is
now
with us but as an attendee
and the host would you please promote
well she's doing that i'll just keep
going and come back representative mckay
president
representatives
no
i don't see him
representative knurk
yes here
representative salloway
uh here
representative cannon here
representative nutteruppum i am here
representative shapiro
president representative woods here
representative merchant
here
representative pearson
everyone is here except for
representative nelson his representative
webber
oh appears to hear her voice so
excuse me my ipad plays funny games with
muting and unmuting and when you called
on me i said present and i guess i was i
was still muted but i am present
representatives now i'm learning how to
read your lips
oh good to you
would whomever i'll have to watch my
language
representative you may continue
thank you very much i don't know where
from
yes all right no thank you very much my
um where'd i put the bill there it is
okay so yeah i had a follow-up question
that was just an issue that
on page seven when we talk about the
notarized certification signed by a
licensed qualified health care provider
i'm just wondering is requiring it to be
notarized as
a bar which might be quite difficult to
achieve because for many providers in
the office there's no notary there and
for them to take time out and go to a
notary to get that notarized
seems like a burden that is higher than
we place on any of these other
uh
record changes is that is it a higher
burden or not is it something that we
should maintain or should we make it a
little less of a burden
um i agree it's a burden um it at the um
i know some people were concerned that
someone would sign the form with some
information that may be invalid and it
may be a forged signature and that by
having it
notarized
essentially
the statement that it was reviewed by
when i got my information changed for
the
for the state of massachusetts
as well as
to get my passport changed
they wanted to see a notarized form
so i felt this was appropriate but i
also know that for me to get a physician
to change my to put sign the form in
front of a notary that it cost me
seventy dollars up there
to pay for their time to go to a notary
now i've heard from others where someone
within the physician's office
has been a notary and can and can do
that for them
and as a follow-up to you yeah as a
follow-up to your question about forms
over the past two years when we were
discussing a similar bills
the vital records office was working
hand-in-hand with the nashua clerk's
office to develop a form
so i i don't think it would be a problem
for me to go back to those individuals
who divide our records office and say
continue the effort that you started
over the past two years just complete
that form and then make it available
online
and available to the court to the
clerk's office
i know there are people with their hands
up
and i'm going to come back to you but
i'm going to temporarily move to another
speaker
who is a
psychiatrist and has a 10 o'clock client
so i am going to make a little detour in
what we're doing and i promise those
with questions for representative cannon
will be able to address them shortly the
chair calls
and please bring into the meeting dr
jillian
i'm going to pronounce schuliberg it
could be schilaber and
and then i couldn't hear you
you're right it's silver
okay good thank you and please let us
know who you are what you do and
then we'll hear your testimony
certainly thank you so i am a
psychologist here in the state of new
hampshire
um
and i am appreciate the time to speak to
this bill and thank you for recognizing
i have a client that's coming soon and i
do also want to address thank you
representative cannon for letting me
know the description of the history of
this bill and the desire really to try
to streamline the process of the
documentation
i just had a
couple of questions regarding the
language of the bill i have just three
points that i'd like to make and please
um
stop me at any point um but i've been
hearing a lot of
interchange between the words sex and
gender and i was just kind of curious
about that a little bit
more um
just to hear a little bit more about
that because in the bill the analysis
section speaks to sex and then the body
refers to gender
and i just wasn't sure represent ken i
think
you were you were referring to people
that have had sex change operations so
we're talking about um
changes to anatomy versus
um the more fluid kind of expression of
gender so i just was curious about that
about that in the bill
because
i'm wondering about the changes from
my understanding as a developmental
psychologist is
our
sex is an objective term it's a term
that's defined actually prenatally
a few different places first for the 10
to 12 week gestational blood work we
determine sex and then at 20 weeks
gestation there's a sonogram picture
that shows the anatomy and some other
measurements that
refer to sex and then at birth the
doctor
or midwife whoever's there
confirmed sex based on the observation
of genitalia so i just was curious about
i want to make sure that i'm
understanding the language of the bill
referring to sex versus gender
and
the
the need of the documentation to be more
streamlined i want to just make sure i'm
speaking to the same thing that you're
presenting
i agree with you
there's there's
we've all we have had that challenge
especially within the
the transgender community
as a whole um
in this case
we're talking about some legal
documentation
and the rsa originally refers to a sex
change
operation
and on the birth certificate it refers
to sex
on the documentation
to change that information
on the birth certificate would be
extremely difficult and costly
and
in the bill that was introduced to
change
our driver's licenses
the the driver's license refers to the
gender
marker information as sex
so from a legal standpoint because of
existing records
we refer to the change in the document
as sex
but we in the community identify it as
gender
so for some folks it's interchangeable
especially here in concord it's been
recognized that the ultimately the
documents that we're working with
it's listed as sex so as such
that's the field that's the information
dr silver you may continue
yeah so um i just was
looking through the rest of the bill and
there's a
the determination that under my
professional opinion that i could
say what gender is and to fill out the
form to allow the person to change their
birth certificate and i just was a
little bit
thrown off by that because i was a
little bit concerned um thinking about
this
fluidity and thinking about the terms
gender and sex
for me how i observe somebody's
gender
might be different from the way they
experience their gender and so i'm just
concerned a little bit about taking the
objectivity in the way that we have on
previous documents to refer to
sex as an objective something that
somebody else tells us right so
absence or
not of certain genitalia or
x x or x y chromosomes
so then for me
undermine the client
psychologist relationship if i were to
say
that the gender the person's presenting
as maybe um
doesn't seem as
subjective to me so for example i
observe somebody is maybe a tomboy right
so somebody's presenting that is
biologically
female but presenting as
wanting to have a masculine gender
identity
so i'm just
concerned a little bit about
i would never want to invalidate my
client for them to feel like i don't
understand them or respect where they're
at
and so i could see feeling pressure to
kind of sign off on the paperwork on
changing their gender because of
their expression
in a way that might not be authentic to
our
our roles together is um
discussing the ways that they express
their gender discussing the ways that
they are able to
do that
so i just
was a little bit concerned about the
possible effects of a therapy of
relationship if
is it's become it becomes subjective
instead of objective so
thinking about sex and gender in that
way so if sex is
observable and gender is fluid and not
clear
um what that might look like in terms of
the relationship between the client and
the psychologist
and the implications for that
does anyone have any questions for dr
silvera
i see two hands up i don't know if
[Music]
the chair recognizes representative
kobalt
thank you um thank you mr chairman uh
representative cannon i i wanted to just
be clear about the marginal note called
for in this bill
the language of the bill does say that
the marginal note will
indicate
that uh
that the change was that the record has
been amended in accordance with this
paragraph so
my understanding there is that the the
reason for the change is therefore
noted on the amended certificate is that
is that understanding correct
i'd have to go back to the vital records
office to see how they make the note on
other
birth record changes whether they
include the reason or not it's it's it's
really up to their policy right now i
was told by the vital records office
that it would have a pointer to the
specific document the original document
um
the chair has invited people to question
dr schilliber and dr schilliber only
my apologies mr chairman okay
um
does anyone have a question for dr
schiller and dr schulberg only because
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and how we will bring back
representative cannon
and
[Music]
questions for her
sega
representative snow
thank you mr chairman am i mute am i
unmuted you're unmuted
yeah thank you
uh
representative cannon i just wondered
it came as a surprise to me today when
you testified
that some of the
some of the
documentation
has a marginal note that says this is a
change however you also said that if the
person appears before the judge and said
they do not want a marginal note if the
marginal note doesn't exist
so does that mean that some of these
people have a marginal note and some of
the people don't
and thinking about some of the comments
that we got on email from the public
a lot of people's concern really was
that there needs to be some note about
what the original birth certificate said
and if the marginal notes removed
i'm just wondering if if that question
has ever been asked and is there a
solution to that if some people's
records
show that the the change was made and uh
by putting the marginal note in it and
thank you for your question
representative snow
the um
if
a court issues an order to change the
birth
certificate
there is no marginal note
and in fact a
that's essentially for the past 15 years
any court ordered
birth certificate change
does not have a marginal note
a person
after after this bill were to be passed
once they go to the clerk's office and
the forms are processed and sent to the
vital records office a marginal note
will be added to a birth record based on
this procedure
if
a
gen a
has been changed and the individual goes
to the court and gets a court order
to change their birth record
that won't have
which in that case for many of the of
the community of people that would have
a need to change their records
that is important to them is to not have
a marginal note on their birth
certificate and they can do so if they
go to a judge and get that order
this does not change the from how things
are processed from the original rsa the
the
changes that we
are
we've been proposing here
would
still require a marginal note
follow-up
and let's follow up
you and as far as you can tell nothing
you've heard
makes the fact that this will be
somewhat inconsistent whether the
marginal note or not is not really an
it won't be essentially it wouldn't be a
problem uh some of some of the gender
community
has already flagged that they don't they
think that would be a problem for them
but we have already made them aware they
can go to the court talk with the judge
he can issue the order and they can get
a birth certificate without a marginal
note
thank you representative for your
testimony the chair now calls chris
herb shell and again pardon me if i get
it wrong chris spiritual is a lobbyist
with legal advocates and defenders
and uh
hello okay can you hear me thank you
hi thank you chairperson thank you
members of the committee my name is
chris urchill i'm an attorney with glbtq
legal advocates and defenders better
known as glad
um we are new england's go-to lgbtq
legal rights organization
um and i'm also a new hampshire licensed
attorney um
i think this bill is a no-brainer and i
can tell you why
um the bill only changes the process for
how transgender people update the gender
marker on their birth records and
there's no change at all to the standard
um today courts are using their valuable
limited resources to hold hearings and
to issue orders on gender markers this
is largely unnecessary
in other words it's pointless red tape
there's no reason that a judge needs to
issue an order about a person's gender
in fact judges in new hampshire today
defer to medical professionals to tell
them whether a person has transitioned
from one gender to another
um you might hear that judges apply
different standards inconsistently
so it's possible under the status quo
that different judges would evaluate the
meaning of gender transition in
different ways but it's pretty much
universal at this point at least to my
personal knowledge and experience that
judges simply listen to the doctors
which makes sense the major
inconsistency that we see is that some
judges want to hear directly from
doctors in the form of testimony while
others accept medical records and notes
as sufficient evidence of gender
transition so that inconsistency it's
unnecessarily confusing and cumbersome
so hb 295 sets a single standard and
rather than putting judges in the middle
of the conversation the bill puts the
medical professionals on record
attesting to the person's gender
transition
and so um i want to point out that under
rsa 5-c 14
a person would be guilty of a felony for
falsifying such a statement
um so so there's a there's a strong
safeguard and in fact that kind of the
question came up about notarization
being a barrier there's already a
safeguard for fraud
which is that a medical professional's
um falsification of a record would be a
felony okay
for a little bit of extra historical
context in addition to whatever what
you've already heard i just want to
explain we used to understand that
treatment for gender dysphoria we used
to understand it differently um so
gender dysphoria is a medical condition
that's characterized by clinical
distress due to the incongruence between
a person's assigned sex on one hand and
their gender identity on the other hand
gender dysphoria is a serious medical
condition but it's highly treatable
and stated really simply treatment for
gender dysphoria is gender transition so
it used to be that a person's gender
transition was understood commonly by
one or more surgeries
now we understand that treatment for
gender dysphoria is much more
individualized and that what is
appropriate treatment for one person
might not be appropriate for another
person
treatment for gender dysphoria usually
involves some combination of social
transition
so social transition is one thing
hormone therapy and sometimes one or
more surgeries but different people have
different needs and i want to point out
that one element of social transition
might be updating identification
documents like birth records so in that
sense correcting the gender marker on
your birth certificate can be part of
your medical treatment
so we do not want to incentivize surgery
for people who don't need surgery
especially young people
so that's why there's no surgical
requirement today instead the question
is whether a person has had appropriate
medical treatment and that's the
standard that judges use in new
hampshire today and that's the standard
that will apply if hb 295 passes
um so leaving it to medical
professionals to attest to whether a
person's gender is different from what
appears on the birth certificate that's
what makes the most sense uh this bill
safeguards against abuse by making it a
felony to include false information on
the application i want to point out that
in subpart b
of the um of the bill there is a
reference to an application that um
that reference is enough to justify the
creation of a form uh but i would not be
opposed personally to um to an amendment
that makes that uh more directive but
the application is referenced in part b
um
and
yeah i i am really proud to be
supporting this bill i hope that it
passes unanimously um and i'm really um
excited to to to support it so if you
have any questions i'm happy to answer
them
thank you counselor but before i call on
anyone for a question representative
nelson if you would identify that you
mute yourself please representative
we still can't hear you
here we go am i right representative
bill nelson i'm in my home in brookfield
and the electorate just came on
thank you
and any questions
for chris herschel
representative gay
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my questions laurel i have three
i'll read them all at once so you can
decide
um
the sex and gender
terminology should that be just used
together
sex slash gender because throughout this
bill
i'm not asking you for the legality of
the bill but for the meaning of the way
it's used in your opinion would that be
cover all bases
so sex slash gender
then do any other states
allow to make copies of the birth
certificate
that doesn't have a marginal note for
the people when they request copy but it
puts it on the original
so there's a record that there are two
birth tickets
and then
i
this probably isn't your question but i
need to know who makes the form
here
the form that's been prescribed
who's supposed to make it so those are
my three questions
um so i'll start with the third question
and work backwards i don't know the
answer to the third question and that's
uh so hopefully somebody else can answer
that for you um as to the second
question about whether other states
allow you to obtain if i understand
correctly you are asking if uh if a
birth certificate has a marginal note
but on the original but a copy can be
obtained without the marginal note
and i believe that there are other
states but i would have to check to
confirm that and if you'd like me to i
can do some research and get back to the
committee with that information about
whether other states do that um
uh so so is that is that something you
would like me to do
yes thank you
okay and then to the first question
about the use of the terms sex and
gender i just want to say in my legal
opinion there is no uh definitional
difference between the terms sex and
gender from a legal perspective and um
i'm not qualified to speak to whether
those terms have
any meaning outside of the legal context
independent but i do um i do know that
doctors in new hampshire and judges in
new hampshire have been relying on the
term sex change uh to to you know that's
the that's the that's the um current
legal uh term that's in the statute and
um and and that's
a person's gender transition has been
sufficient to meet that standard so i
think legally there's no difference
between the word sex and gender and so
for the purposes of this bill it just
it's it's insignificant and so yes if it
were sex slash gender sex and or gender
or just using the terms interchangeably
i think they would all have the same
outcome
legally speaking
council just for your information before
you um start the research
uh i had hoped we would get everything
done
today and next monday
i that's what i hope i don't think
that's going to happen which means our
last meeting will be on the
thursday a week from now
and that means we're done
we have to be done and so any
information that comes back to us
if possible
um
by next monday
but definitely
drop down a date for us is a week from
thursday okay i can i can um have an
email to the committee by
monday
i just didn't want you to do all that
work for nothing
all right thank you
any other questions
for chris
herschel
see none thank you counselor for your
testimony
thank you
i now call into the meeting jeffrey
johnston
this speaks from a
good morning everyone can you hear me
we can thank you um well i basically i
just simply wanted to testify
this morning because i myself had lived
as a transsexual woman for over 22 years
however at the age of 41 i became i had
a close to death experience when someone
had tried to kill me
that being said
the spirit of god was drawing me to him
and i was you know truly unaware of it
at that time in my life
god began giving me external visions
as to how i was living my life as a
transgender woman
bound to homosexuality
and god himself had showed me
that he had seen everything that i had
done in life in trying to become a woman
then god said to me he said honey this
isn't you this is what the devil has
done to you
so i say all this to say
that a lot of people are totally unaware
of the fact that there is a spiritual
world
so no matter what a person chooses to
put on the birth certificate
what truly matters is what god himself
has already said in the bible in regards
to one's gender
god says in the book of genesis chapter
5 verse 2 that he
created the male and female and that he
blessed them and called the mankind in
the day that they were created
so why would we want to change what god
said was good after he created what he
created
so after hearing i mean i myself lived
so many years as a trans transgender
woman thinking that that was truth
but god said to me that there were
simply lies that i came into agreement
with
so
being ignorant of the knowledges of the
truths of god's written word
made me sis uh you know susceptible to
believing every wind of doctrine or
teaching teaching that this
world had to offer me
simply because i was lacking the truth
of god's word
god loves transgenders he loves every
human being on this earth
but we have to realize
what truly matters is what god says
god himself has magnified his word the
bible far above his name
i think we as people have we really come
to this point in life
where we give people the options to
change their gender on their birth
certificate
that's just a question to chew on
i was so scared i don't mean to
interrupt you but when i had my personal
encounters with god
if you could have seen what he showed me
i i just sat sat there and trembled
in my shoes because i was you know
standing now before
a living god who is true yes he's the
the invisible god
but you know if you draw near to god
and just simply ask him to reveal
himself to you he'll make himself known
to you
i'm going to stop your testimony here
because we are woefully behind schedule
but i am going to open it up to
questions and the first one comes from
uh the chair mark pearson
and um
i know of a few
folks
who lived as transgenders and for
different reasons you mentioned one of
them i know of others
why they went back to
the gender on their original birth
certificate so my question when i have a
chance to talk to them and now my
question for you is
was it when you decided and you gave
this your reasons for deciding it
you
sought to resume your identity as
it was
on your birth certificate
was that relatively easy for you to do
when you made your mind up that's what
you should do
was it easy for me to change my mind is
that what you're asking me was it
easy for you
to
go back to resuming your life and your
self-identity
as a man once again well it was
incredibly difficult and i don't wash it
upon anybody especially after they hear
the words of truth from god himself
like i said i lived most of my life as a
transsexual woman um you know thinking i
was doing the right thing
um however
i never changed my birth certificate i
never changed the fact that um
you know i was living as a transgender
female
um but
it was it was difficult there was many
tears i mean because when god himself
comes into your life and he
supernaturally changes your mind and as
you develop a relationship with him and
read his word his written word the bible
it supernaturally renews your mind and i
wasn't aware of all those things before
you know coming to know god
so yes it was incredibly difficult to
have to go through
uh changing my license back to mail
because now here i am in my right mind
supernaturally by the power of god
and um
so now i've got to he supernaturally
made me hate the breast implants that i
had for over 16 years and now i had to
go through different procedures to try
to
go back to my original gender because
god
his spirit you know now lives in my
heart so he just works with me and just
supernaturally
took what the devil meant for bad in my
life and that is what's significant is
because people aren't aware of the
demonic activity in the spirit realm mr
johnson you're re-looping you're
repeating what you've said before i wish
representative cushman for we'll have
one question go ahead yes uh will you
please send us your testimony via email
to the committee
if you haven't already
well um cornerstone action they actually
have my uh live testimony that they
filmed
is that i'm sure yeah can you please
just send us an email
i'll do that yes
thank you very much the chair now
recognizes gene gruska
and you've been before this committee
before and my memory serves me correctly
you would are with the aclu of new
hampshire
good morning thank you mr chair and
members of the committee you are quite
right my name is jeannie herroska and
i'm the political director for the
american civil liberties union of new
hampshire i really appreciate the
opportunity to testify this morning in
support of
hb295
and i'm i'm going to make just a couple
points because i i really appreciate
everything that representative cannon
has already
noted um and as you know new hampshire
law already allows a person to correct
the sex marker on their birth record so
this is not changing the law in that
respects all it's doing is making the
process uh easier and actually making
the process uh align with the process
that the state already utilizes
for correcting other state issued ids
and that's the point i really want to
underscore is that the goal should be to
have a process for amending state issued
ids across the board so if you have an
affidavit from your health care provider
you can use that to go and correct your
driver's license and you can then use it
to go and correct your birth record
to have distinct
processes remembering different state
issued ids just doesn't make any sense
it risks having people walk around with
inconsistent state issued ids which
doesn't help anybody there are many
situations where you present both you
present a birth record and a driver's
license right you're starting a new job
you're getting a mortgage to have
inconsistent state ids
really risks discrimination
it makes great that somebody uh is
transgender which is discriminatory and
so that our goal with this bill
is to just ease the process to take the
courts out of it
and really allow people to amend their
state issued ids at the same time you
can amend your driver's license you can
amend your birth record they'll be
consistent and that should be the goal
and
so sorry for that um so our we really
appreciate this bill and just see it as
a way
uh to bring our statutes in line with
each other um it doesn't change the
standard it just makes the process a
little bit easier and aligns it with the
process we already use
for amending drivers licenses
and with that i'm happy to answer any
questions
the chair has a question for you
i'm not following
much of what goes on in washington um
at the moment but
is there a movement in washington d.c
to make a standard
procedure on this nationally
and i guess a follow-up to that would be
could they or is this something that
reverts to the states so whatever
washington does they wouldn't make
one standard for everybody
uh
i'm not sure i'm following the
conversations in washington i know that
there is consideration about
uh passports which is something
issued by the federal government but
driver's licenses are issued by the
state so i think it's perfectly
right for the state of new hampshire to
amend its own process for its own
driver's licenses
thank you
seeing none thank you for your testimony
good to see you again
and
can you hear me
yes yeah sorry for that delay
yes my name is shannon mcginley and i am
a volunteer executive director for
cornerstone action
and cornerstone recommends that the
committee please vote and expedient to
legislate on hb
295 relating to the initiation of
amending the birth certificates
so this in no way undermines the dignity
of any new hampshire resident in fact
all
we all have a common interest in
maintaining accurate fact-based records
as they relate to public health identity
theft and investigations into
questionable deaths and it's been said
that it's already in state statute under
section 5-c colon 87 part 5
to amend the birth certificates through
a court order if they've had a sex
change but this bill will actually amend
it so that one it's just one's identity
and not a sex change not the process of
court order and i would suggest that it
would swing the door open for
vital records to be changed much more
easily much more frequently
and society has an important interest in
maintaining accurate vital records
especially birth records
and maintaining accurate birth
records does not violate federal or
state law we've been collecting vital
statistics for over 500 years especially
the births the deaths the marriages
based on consistent and well-established
and understood criteria week today the
vital records offices record over 11
million vital events annually in the
united states and there is simply no
federal or state law that requires us to
change those criteria to replace
objectively defined sex with the
subjective classification of gender
identity for example in the covid um
pandemic it's there's an example of
where having accurate information of a
person's sex is necessary for diagnosis
treatment and better understanding of
the disease i've seen numerous articles
um lining laying out how males are being
identified as a risk factor for death
and icu admission for example
and i'll include one of those articles
in my written testimonies
also um
allowing individuals to alter their
vital records including birth
certificates based on subjective
feelings or experiences undermines the
government and the people's interest in
having
an accurate vital record database so for
example if we're able to streamline and
make this easier to change their gender
identity
what if you have a situation where a
gentleman in his 70s who believes that
he has the appearance and identity of a
40 year old man the state would not
allow him to retroactively change his
the date of birth by 30 years in order
to conform to how he looks or how he
feels or the same might be true of a
person who's been born in new mexico but
feels more at home as an iowan while
that person may identify as an iowan it
doesn't change the fact that he was born
in new mexico where do we draw the line
in terms of what it is that we're
changing on
our our vital records several states
don't allow for marginal notes and i
fear that the transgender community
would come back to remove this marginal
note therefore just completely wiping
out any kind of record of what it was
originally
you know facts can never be
discriminatory birth certificates death
records and so forth are attended they
are intended to document facts efforts
to attribute to any further purposes to
them such as affirming a person's
internal sense of age their sex or
locality of birth or counter to the
government's vital interest in having
accurate information
and furthermore in america we've become
more tolerant accepting of individuals
who identify as transgender than ever
before and in fact you could argue that
their biological sex is an intrinsic
part of their story
treating them with the dignity and
respect that all persons are entitled to
receive does not mean that we erase
certain factual information especially
when that helps the government better
protect its health the health and safety
of its citizens
under new hampshire law the birth
certificate is required to include the
sex of the individual and factual
information regarding the person sex is
among the vital statistics that new
hampshire law requires to be maintained
but yet in hb 295's proposed revisions
to our law attempt to erase any mention
of the objective biological designation
of sex and replace it with the vague
term of gender identity to establish
gender identity one would only show that
it is their sincerely held belief
verified by someone in the medical and
counseling community i would also just
point out to you that this bill refers
to minors and allowing them to change
their um birth records and i believe
that it further pushes them down the
road of gender dysphoria and studies
have shown that 80 to 90 percent of
adolescents will identify as their
biological sex as they pass through
puberty if
if their alternative gender identity is
not being affirmed to allow the process
of puberty etc to take over and i feel
like that this would just further you
know encourage them to go through that
process unnecessarily and new
hampshire's vital records should not be
based upon subjective feelings however
sincerely held rather they should be
based upon the facts including factual
information regarding a person a
person's biological sex
at birth
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you to the committee for your time
the chair has one and
i'm not a medical person although i'm
usually surrounded by such uh and i
don't think you are a medical person but
doesn't don't we
extract policies on
infant
various other things based on what that
birth certificate says um
in other words that gives us information
and now the information
were to become
changed
correct like say for example like
yeah yes i mean i was trying to allude
to that in my testimony about collecting
health statistics so say for example if
you want to look at like the infants i
know i was using the example of covet
just because we're all in the middle of
living it but to your point though mr
chairman if you take into
the example from like flint michigan
with the lead contamination and so forth
that you know certainly you would want
to see patterns of contamination and how
it's affecting you know infants and
children and so forth if it bear has any
bearing on the males and the females and
so forth so yes i would agree with your
statement
thank you for your testimony
thank you
the
cheer now
and i hope she's still with us calls
sophia beyond
dolilo and again pardon me if i
mispronounced your name
who represents new hampshire high school
democrats
hi can you hear me
we can thank you
all right uh thank you mr chair and
members of the committee for taking my
testimony today my name is sofia
biandolila you actually said it
perfectly um i'm 14 i live in manchester
and i'm speaking today on behalf of the
new hampshire high school democrats in
support of hb 295
hb 295 would create a standardized
process to allow thousands in new
hampshire to be correctly identified on
their birth certificate doing so would
have multiple benefits first of all many
transgender people suffer from a
condition called gender dysphoria the
american psychiatric association defines
this as a psychological distress that
results from an incongruence between one
sex assigned at birth and one's gender
identity
this dysphoria could be triggered very
easily by a situation where someone is
not correctly identified on their birth
certificate
for many trans people being associated
with their gender assigned at birth can
can bring back traumatizing memories and
create a stressful situation that might
seriously impact their mental health
secondly in a situation where a person's
birth records do not align with how they
look and present there could be relating
resulting issues when that person tries
to sign up for a government program or
get a driver's license or whatever it
may be because they will be forced to
explain this difference and not only
would this open them up to misgendering
and transphobia but it could be
traumatic for many of these people for
all the same reasons
the language of the bill says that a
licensed health care provider must
provide
evidence that in simpler terms the
person trying to change their birth
certificate is actually transgender and
although that might sound a little too
forgiving for some of you um i can i
want to emphasize that with my
experience with counselors and doctors
and other transgender people who are in
similar situations to me
that type of decision would not be taken
lightly by these providers it would not
be something somebody could just do if
they wanted to whenever they want um
it's like these are licensed
professionals in our state and they know
how to weigh the pros and cons of these
decisions and they take their practice
very seriously
um and this bill would allow those most
qualified to make these decisions and
determine what is best for their
patients um there are a few things that
i haven't written down but
i just like to point out that um in my
own research i've seen studies that have
proven that even among adolescents who
transition at maybe an earlier age
detransitioning is not a major part of
like the live trans experience in this
country um i i saw a study i can't
remember exactly what was done but it
was very recently um
where they studied about 400 people and
there was only two
who had any sort of regrets after
transitioning and they also studied
adolescence in that study i believe
so i don't think that detransitioning is
a major thing that we have to be worried
about and again this is just a very
simple
um simple change it wouldn't be opening
up to fraud or any sort of
skewed data i don't think that would be
a major issue and even if it would ski
the data it would skew the data towards
being more accurate because it would
accurately represent how these people
are
identifying and presenting to the rest
of the world
so in summary allowing transgender
people to change the indicator on their
birth certificate would be a simple fix
that would prevent traumatic situations
and would significantly improve the
lives of thousands of transgender people
in new hampshire and for all of these
reasons i asked the committee to
recommend optopass on hb295 thank you
for your time thank you very much and i
um
skipped over somebody that i should have
called earlier and i apologize for that
uh kelly bruniak from the new hampshire
good morning can everyone hear me we can
hear you all right great i will be quick
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak
we just wanted to mention although we
are neutral on this bill that the dmv is
watching it because we want to make sure
that
how what our requirements are to change
the gender designation
on a new hampshire driver license or
non-driver id card is consistent with
anything else that is out there we do as
the representative cannon has
stated we do have a process in place
we will make sure that any rules that we
have need to be updated we will be
following that
we also will be making sure that we are
looking at updating our rules to include
physicians assistants
as someone that can complete our current
form
all right thank you for the opportunity
thank you very much
good morning
good morning okay
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for taking my testimony which
is against house bill 295 my name is
richard johnson and i am a physician
a person's gender or gender gender
identity does not change their sex at
present one can take hormones have top
and bottom surgery all to make one more
comfortable in their chosen gender be it
male
female fluid or neutral
but you cannot change your chromosomes
the purpose of a birth certificate is to
record factual data not preferences
i might re
i might prefer to be viewed and treated
either older or younger than i am but
that does not entitle me to change my
birth date
there's another factor to consider each
year a portion of the population is born
with biological characteristics such as
sex chromosomes gonads genital hormones
or a combination that don't fit textbook
definitions of male or female
the number of births where the baby is
intersex have been reported to be as low
as
0.018 percent or as high as 1.7 percent
depending on which conditions are
counted as intersex
for the child with both an ovarian a
testicle which do they want to keep
will they want to identify as male or
female
how will the child who has a testicle
and a uterus but no vagina
want to identify
these individuals need to be given the
opportunity to participate in the
decisions for surgical medical care and
make their own decision on sexual
identification
i call this to your attention because it
is in the area of disorders or
differences of sexual development that
there should be a box on the birth
certificate for the physician to check
that says indeterminate
the purpose of the birth certificate is
to record factual data not gender
preferences gender identity or sexual
orientation
this bill should not become law because
one it does not address the problem of
children born with disorders of sexual
development and secondly it negates
biological fact with gender preference
this is not the purpose of a birth
certificate thank you for taking my
testimony
thank you very much dr johnson
the chair calls
emmett leblanc
i'm not finding mr leblanc in the list
here um
so
then the chair calls barbara mcleod
[Music]
hi um i am the mother of a transgender
teenager who is um set to testify and i
think if it's possible for me to have
lane be pulled up instead of me i think
her testimony is going to be more
compelling and she has to go to class
so is it possible for you she's on her
own zoom it would is it possible for you
to grab her instead of me
i don't have her on the list but
i'm right here can you hear me right now
i can hear you lane
uh we can swap her for you
that would be great i'll just say that
um from a parent's perspective i've been
through a lot of paperwork and a lot of
stress trying to get her um birth
certificate changed and um this would be
hugely beneficial i agree with the um
okay we're going to take one mcleod and
i think you want your daughter yes okay
go go lane
uh hello um my name is lane joslin and
i'm a currently a sophomore in high
school i was born in portsmouth new
hampshire
my birth certificate says male but i am
very much a girl
my birth certificate determines all of
my forms of id driver's license passport
social security card insurance card
s.a.t registration financial aid for
school my season ski pass and house
forms
every time i look at my passport that
says mail a feeling of deep sadness
ensues the fact that my own gender isn't
reflected in that and an idea i use
often is to be honest painful and
infuriating
whenever i travel i use my passport as
an id
each time i stand before an airport
official i am scared and anxious i see
them notice that my id says boy they
look up at me and back to the passport
and then back to me looking befuddled my
heart starts beating and i start
sweating petrified that i'll get pulled
aside or questioned in public
this spring i am attempting to take the
driving exam
my license should reflect who i am i
should not be
i should not be misgendered every single
time i go to a new doctor or be forced
to explain things to the sat board with
the hope that they will update their
information so it doesn't disqualify me
this bill would streamline the process
for me currently i'm waiting for a court
date to get my birth certificate amended
i hope and pray that the judge who hears
my case understands what it means to be
transgender and doesn't force me to wait
until i get gender confirmation surgery
i have a letter from a doctor explaining
that i have been living as my authentic
self for six years and have undergone
medical treatment
being transgender is not easy but this
was not a choice it's who i am i have
learned to deal with it and i'm so
fortunate that i've been completely
accepted by my family friends in school
i do all of my studies play on the
soccer team and am involved in my
community
please don't make it harder for
teenagers like me the current process
causes unnecessary pain and is
humiliating i don't think you would want
your kids to go through this thank you
for your time
good morning
good
morning uh
chair members of the committee i'm
speaking to you this morning as another
mother of a transgender person
except that this time we actually went
through the current process to change
our daughter's birth certificate
and i'm here to tell you that it was
horribly difficult
i sent you an email to this effect dated
february 25th and so i uh
i hope that that is in your record and
you will take a look at that for the
details
but you know i am a new hampshire
licensed attorney
and i was challenged with this process
it was very onerous my husband myself
and my daughter needed to leave work and
leave school to go to the courthouse
this was before the pandemic
um we
had to manage our daughters and our own
emotions as we sat in front of a judge
who grilled us and
appeared that perhaps the change would
not be granted
we had to pay a hundred and ten dollar
filing fee uh to go through this process
and so our family is strongly in favor
of this bill we hope that you will uh
vote otp on this bill and i welcome any
questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you the chairman calls
i read it as valen
werner
hello can you hear me
yes
uh good morning um
my name is valen werner um i'm here to
express my support for hb295
um i support this bill because i'm
familiar with how difficult it can be to
change documents like birth certificates
um and i'm hoping my perspective on what
this process is actually like will be
useful to the committee
um i was born in pennsylvania and since
last summer i've been going through the
process of changing the gender marker on
my birth certificate which was completed
just a few days ago
pennsylvania and new hampshire have
different processes but their processes
have similar weaknesses
to change someone's gender on the birth
record pennsylvania requires a doctor to
write a letter stating that person has
had appropriate clinical treatment for
gender transition
like new hampshire's current requirement
of a court order indicating a sex change
this forces transgender people who want
to update their birth certificate to
rely on another individual to decide
whether they've undergone enough medical
treatment to correct their documents
the first two doctors i approached about
writing a letter refused to do so
because even though i had been
identifying and living full-time as a
man for three years at the time they
weren't sure what the state meant by
appropriate clinical treatment for
gender transition so they did not want
to state whether i'd had it
both of the first two doctors told me
they were willing to write that my
gender identity was male but not to
declare that i had done enough to
transition
and i believe i was lucky that i was
able to find a third doctor who agreed
that my birth certificate should be
changed
this bill would allow people born in new
hampshire to avoid problems like the one
i had
after having treated me as their patient
any of my doctors would have been
willing to affirm that i am a man and
could be reasonably expected to be a man
for the foreseeable future it was clear
to them as medical professionals and
according to this bill that would have
been enough
the one characteristic all transgender
people have in common is that our gender
is different from the one we were
assigned at birth so it makes sense that
this should be the basis for updating
our documents
requiring that an individual prove
anything beyond that ultimately leads to
unequal circumstances for people who
have difficulty accessing courts or
whatever medical care meets the
definition of a sex change and so it
prevents people with a legitimate need
to amend their records from doing so
it also allows for discrimination
against transgender people by leaving it
up to a judge who may not have the
appropriate medical knowledge to decide
whether their level of medical
transition is sufficient so i am in full
support of improving this process and
recommending ought to pass on hb 295.
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you and the final one who signed
in by the deadline
um good morning hi i'm nancy i actually
signed in for house bill 502
i thought
you know what
you're right i'm good
so
all right seeing that there's nobody
else signed in
um
the chair closes the hearing on house
bill 295
and declares a five-minute
stretch
break
and bathroom
for four years i've been in this room
and never realized those windows are
different sizes
those are big and these are little when
can you hear me those windows
so
i just wanted to thank whichever of the
hosts rescued me from the attendee list
i actually used the proper link
but apparently it's only usable once so
if i vanish again i will
join via the attendee list and somebody
we'll be glad to attend to that
representative
we also have a back-up plan if we lose
our
always nice to have duplicate systems in
place
okay
5.02
so
you know lucy your comment about
duplicate systems applied in the
operating room too
you always wanted to have two prosthesis
one to drop on the floor and one to use
right bill
can't hear you real well
what's that i remember once when i was a
resident i was assisting a pediatric
ophthalmologist and a cataract i think i
was a beginning second-year resident and
he suddenly passed out and was lying on
the floor
redundancy yeah
nothing like being thrown in off the
talk about picking things up off the
floor we had a gal come in with a
motorcycle accident which left her
kneecap on the pavement
judiciously cleaned it up sterilized it
put it in this
and she did fine
so
yeah and you always hated when you
dropped the bone graft on the floor that
was a bad one too
oh unfortunately i never did that
you're a structural graft too
not little chips
okay the chair
starts the hearing on house bill 502
establishing a committee to study
whether adequate funds are being set
aside from the tobacco fund for youth
and young adult prevention
i think i know that's what it means to
help oh yeah to help preserve long-term
health that's what we're trying to do
and the the chair recognizes
representative tucker to present the
bill
uh who's ever hosting can you see
representative
okay um very it's a very brief
braille one page
and it just asks
to establish a committee
to study
whether adequate funds are being said
excuse me point of order normally we
would have a a committee member simply
present the bill so
please would somebody stop
i would be glad to be glad to oh you do
okay
and it lists the membership of three
members of the house and three members
of the senate
and the duties to study whether there's
enough funds
um
dr cycerlo from dhhs
i'm i'm told this this may be old news
because we're quite a bit late starting
um can speak about the current program
tarallo
dr dr chirala hi
welcome back to the committee
good morning uh
chair representative pearson and the
committee members thank you for giving
me this opportunity
i'm here just to talk about what we are
currently doing um about the the youth
prevention uh just to give you the
background the department supports the
tobacco prevention activities through
our tobacco prevention and cessation
program
under this program um it's actually
funded through a federal uh federal
hassle of state resources
and we provide services on on four areas
one is uh prevents initiate initiation
among the youth and young adults promote
quitting tobacco quitting among adult
and youth
again eliminate exposure to secondhand
smoke and identify and eliminate
tobacco-related disparities among
population groups
so we um in the last five years the
department has actually expanded a lot
of our youth prevention and intervention
services
um in the last two years uh especially
given in new hampshire there has been a
rapid increase in the ends we call it
electronic nicotine delivery system or
e-cigarette products um
for our general consumption that's the
e-cigarettes that's how they are defined
especially among our high school aged
youth
which is a great concern not just only
for us uh in the department but across
our many of our stakeholders as well as
from our legislative members too
what we have seen is in the last 2019
new hampshire youth risk behavior survey
we had a high school age youth reporting
current use of electronic cigarettes
almost around 34 percent and if you
compare with the nash nationwide it's
only 27 percent
so that's a big uh big number to think
about and what we also have seen is that
the many of the studies have been
showing that the flavored e-cigarettes
actually has fueled this epidemic or
this this this kind of um uh increase
because when we found like 90 percent of
youth e-cigarette users actually report
using a flavored product and 75 70 of
them actually cite flavors as the reason
for their use so not many know about
that there's a tobacco component in
these flavors too so that's a bigger
kind of
concern for us
so two areas that the department has
focused on supporting the youth programs
is on youth engagement
uh we feel that youth are critical in
this
in the public health uh prevention
strategies they offer us like you know
as we all know they are they have a
different take on things from social
media to
um what areas they want to hear the
messaging how they want to hear the
messaging about the prevention
so we actually work with our um
we act our provider our tobacco
prevention association program actually
engaged youth
in uh youth groups in this uh focus on
understanding what are the strategies
that we need to talk about how do we
want to provide um those prevention and
intervention campaigns
so
with that in mind we actually in the
state fiscal 20 and 21 we actually
launched a multi-platform prevention
and intervention campaign it's called
save your breath new hampshire it's
actually you can find it on our uh on a
web page on our website uh uh it's save
your breath uh new hampshire dot org
so this actually was this was this when
we with this campaign we actually had
around one million engagement
uh and impressions so
with that information like there were
fifty thousand peop fifty thousand kids
who are interested to learn about it
this website actually provided a lot of
information on what kind of um info
specifically educational kind of
information like what does wave means
what kind of uh products go into that
vape and all that so that's one of the
area that we've worked on
the second area that we actually came
out is called my life my quit
it's a um
it's a youth tobacco cessation program
so how we have tobacco quit line that's
focused on adults 18 and over the my
life microwave was very much focused on
their youth tobacco prevention
so uh this this one actually
uh specifically adapted to include
vaping and new ways of how to um reach
the coach like a
quit coaching a coach uh who will help
them to quit the tobacco products or eat
vaping products and they actually use
the live text messaging online chat they
provide a lot of um what you call as
educational information to to the uh to
the youth who are interested
and these are like you know they are
very um youth are very savvy um they are
very savvy on these electronic social
media kind of platforms so this is how
they they could you this is one of the
way we we actually worked to do that so
they actually provide coaches and they
provide very apologize uh dr shirella um
we have actually lost um the committee
room
and i can't hear you so we just wanted
to see if we can uh resolve the
technical issues
oh i'm so sorry do you want me to hold
off till they come on would you mind
because they can't hear anything and
without our chairperson we have no no
way to continue
i understand i can i can i can hold off
[Applause]
well it's certainly been an interesting
day
and it's still early
yeah
you know you sound like you're in a
helicopter
with your me yeah with your headphones
and however your mic is you sound just
like the helicopter guys giving you the
weather report or the
oh
i think of that
it's sunny and windy
it's the ghosts
well it is an old house
[Laughter]
i will refrain from the comment i could
make
yeah cause i don't know if we're being
recorded or not but
that's a good point you are still being
recorded yep
no
yes this is health human services and
elderly houses
i've got an elderly house question for
you
i
the last floor that i finished our house
is over 200 years old so the last floor
i finished they had already painted once
so i just repaint it and i filled all
the gaps between the big pine
things with with caulk and then painted
over it
but there's some that i want to refinish
and what do you fill those gaps with
where all that whatever they use the
granule stuff they use to clock those
fine flooring how do you where do you
i'm trying to figure out how to fill
that so that it doesn't look like it's
caulk when i
restain the floors
oh a floor fill floors yeah
that's hard
that's kind of above my pay grade but i
would say one thing to be careful about
if you're going to refinish which i
some of the
floor finishes even if not paint may
have possibly contained lead
yeah we
i mean even when i was washing the
outside windows i wore gloves and i
washed everything when i was done
because we assumed there was paint
right painted in the trim so yeah no
we're
we've been very careful with some things
that we've found in this house
yeah they can do some really really cool
spectroscopy uh to determine if there's
lead in the layers of paint or finish
below
yeah yeah the walls had very little
paint they had
three four layers of wallpaper
yeah yeah
can you hear us now
yes
we're going to uh recess the bill on
wallpaper
we didn't come to a vote come on
i know i'll take a pasting on that when
i'm sorry
we're going to go back to whatever we
were doing before the power went out
[Music]
don't
try please yes
but i'm actually hanging out over here
don't you hear me now yes and let us
know what your
folks over at dhhs are doing
thank you all again uh do you want me to
begin from the uh uh
the whole thing
no how about halfway through okay thank
you um so just to focus on two main
things that the department has been
working on are youth engagement where we
have established savior breath new
hampshire dot
campaign so where we provide a lot of
information on different fresh
fresh perspectives to about vaping and
why
what the what those public health
prevention strategies are for the youth
uh during last um
we have started this campaign in the
state fiscal 20 and 21 we had around 1
million engagement and impressions uh so
basically that's um i'm not the social
media expert but my understanding is
that one million engagement is uh people
who visited website pull some
information to understand those things
or clicked on the information to get
more details and all that kind of thing
we are planning to actually expand this
further um to use this information to um
like a phase two kind of thing to
continue working with our
youth population to understand
how can we use this approach to include
the middle and junior high school aged
youth in increasing the education on
electronic cigarettes the second piece
that we have started is the my life my
quit again this is a youth tobacco
cessation uh focused um
area that we are providing or what you
call has um it's almost like similar to
the quitline program that's we offer for
the the adults but this one is very much
focused on youth um you uh and uh where
we provide the trained coaches they
actually provide some of the
personalized support uh support for the
youth who are interested in quitting
vaping or vape products and they provide
like you know how to cope with the
stress navigate some
some stressful situations or peer
pressures and even how to build uh
relationships that promote promote that
kind of a tobacco-free identity
and this program is actually is only
available in 21 states including new
hampshire it's a very um
very much tailored to support the youth
for the prop prop
that population
uh again we are we are our future
thought is to use this to expand and
include our communities especially our
school administrations and our school
community and superintendent school
boards to say like you know how can we
use this to support the youth in the
school so that we um they don't lose the
um they it gives them a support system
for for preventing the vaping
um
again we are with one of the biggest
stumbling block for us in the last as
you all know we are going through the
kobe 19 pandemic that limited some of
our work in the school systems so
that's where we are now currently with
uh what we are doing on the youth and we
are hoping to expand these activities
further in in future and we are working
with our our uh behavior health our
bureau of drug and alcohol services also
to expand those uh in-school activities
to support the prevention or preventing
vaping you um
as you uh
expand the program are you putting in
for additional funds because that's
really what the bill is about is seeing
if you have enough money so um could you
speak very briefly to as you expand how
is your expansion the program getting
funded
currently we had um in the last biennium
we had uh we had prioritized vaping and
we received funds from uh in the in the
legislative budget in the in our budget
to support those activities and that's
up that support is continuing we have
identified this as another this helps to
fill our priority area for this budget
too and uh we are continuing to request
more funds to support that activity
the chair recognizes representative
soloway for a question
oh uh thank you mr chairman and uh dr
charles so nice to see you again
um
this is a question uh which i'll pose to
you but it is possible that the chairman
will choose to answer it
the bill stipulates a committee to study
this issue it is my limited
understanding
that
committees
are made up of members of the house only
whereas commissions which are often
impaneled to study issues can be made up
of members of the public as well
um
it would this be better remanded to a
uh
thank you for the question
representatives holloway i don't have
much
understanding or i i don't have uh how
the commission or committee or different
groups work so i don't have the answer
for that i refer back to
uh the committee for that that that
clarity
uh that puts us both on the same page i
was hoping that the committee chair
might jump in and answer it for both of
my comments are right along the same
lines as representative salloway
there is an existing
commission called the
health and human services oversight
committee
which purpose is exactly to deal with
issues um
like this
and it came up recently in another piece
of legislation because they
somewhat cut back on the membership of
that
committee
since this is a function
of health and human services it doesn't
seem to me that this legislation is
needed
at all
and that
it would simply report to the oversight
committee like a whole bunch of other
thank you mr chair and i could speak to
the committee versus commission issue
but only if you would care to have me do
so otherwise i will hold my comments for
another time
when we have time to burn that would be
very instructive
thank you dr psy
always good to see you
thank you all thank you so
much and as promised
the chair recognizes nancy vaughn from
the american heart association who
signed up to testify in fact on this
bill
okay there is my unmute can you hear me
now you're wonderful okay wonderful
thank you so much um for
uh you know giving this bill some
consideration um you know
for the record i'm nancy von government
relations director for the american
heart association in new hampshire
i did sign on in support of house bill
but i don't have any specific
suggestion that it be a committee a
commission or be handed off to another
already established group um to talk
about but i just
urge um that this issue be talked about
and to find a way to um to fund uh this
really important tobacco program um the
uh dr terello went into great detail on
on what it is that they would like to
accomplish
this year um into next year
and um
and then even beyond that there there is
a need for um a tobacco control program
um these are our programs that really
can have a
vast impact on reducing youth tobacco
use and tobacco includes electronic
products it also includes new and
emerging products such as the heat not
burn there are always new products
coming out from the industry so
you know looking at this 10 years ago 15
years ago it's a different world right
now
that needs to be looked at and funding
found now the american heart association
you know looks at the cdc for their
recommendations on what state should be
spending and for new hampshire it's um a
whopping 16.5 million dollars annually
which we have not come close to in the
past the aha would really recommend you
know a state starting at at least 15
percent of the cdc recommendation for
their states for new hampshire that
would be approximately two and a half
million dollars a year so that we have a
ways to go between that and where we're
funding right now but i i really do um
urge you to um to look into this issue
the the state does receive over 240
million dollars a year between tobacco
taxation and master settlement funding
so there are funds there it's just
prioritizing taking some of those funds
and putting it to helping our kids not
start a what could be a lifelong tobacco
problem i also
also back what doctor trello was saying
about
funding
in this current uh budget process
not only their efficiency budget but
also that extra 220 000 per year for
this new initiative
so again i urge you to pass the bill or
amend it in some way that we can
continue this conversation um into the
near future but not to take too much
time to study it
so
yeah since i cheered the oversight
committee
representative soloway reminded us
um
and he's on it as well uh we will be
addressing this very issue
and you may be
happy to learn that
on sunday the chair of finance for the
house presented me a huge stack of
papers
and wanted me to go through it and
um tell him what i thought was really
important so i plan on doing that for
this too so
very good
at it so thank you so much
thank you um
representative merchant you had your
hand up did you
i did mr chairman but i
she answered my question about the
committee versus the commission and also
about
the process of putting this through
the oversight committee versus creating
another committee itself
if it's
pretty much the mind of us
that this is an important task to be
done
but the task to do it is the oversight
committee
then we can exec the bill unanimously
itl
if that's what we all seem to think
if there are people who think oh no we
really do need a separate committee
um
then we'll have a longer discussion
so this isn't a vote this is a um
straw vote
if you would like to execute itl and let
oversight committee handle this very
very legitimate request could you just
all right um yeah um thank you
mr chairman to advocate for the funding
do we need a bill
yeah that's gonna ask thank you
we do yeah we don't need
a bill to advocate for funding this is
this can be done in a couple of ways
um all right would somebody like to move
so move mr chairman
representation
we need to enter an executive session
first you are correct i close
502 and i open an executive session on
502. thank you very much for that
reminder
i get so excited i forgot the protocols
representative soloway moves it out
second
and second is
[Music]
okay
representative
shapiro before we call the role do you
have something
to say
yes
um
perhaps it's um
because the sponsor of the bill didn't
introduce it but
i'm just left without any idea whether
there are serious impediments to funding
these programs which i think their
my general bias would be there probably
are but i didn't i don't have any
specifics about whether there are um
financial impediments to funding these
programs and and
what they are so i just feel like i
don't have enough information
um
to know if there needs to be a committee
to study this so
um
i guess that's a reason to vote for
itl
unless
unless that information is going to be
forthcoming
did anyone receive written testimony
from the bill's sponsor on 502
representative weber
thank you mr chairman well i think from
ms vaughan we have significant testimony
to show us that
the
funding that is allocated for
tobacco prevention and youth is woefully
underfunded by standard seti by the cdc
uh it seems to me that that has been an
issue
that certainly has plagued my 14 years
in the legislature
and the place that it actually the only
place it can actually be addressed is in
the budget
so
it seems to me that people
sorry
yeah
come on
thank you
unless
we can
make an appropriation in our committee
not with this bill because it didn't
have one in it but
a committee via a bill can make an
appropriation but unless that gets
passed and
uh gets passed the finance committee and
into the budget it doesn't matter what
we do
and as the chair has a great deal of
information and and is actually being
consulted by folks from finance which is
a wonderful thing
um we have a very good
way of getting some information to them
um and i think that the
in addition to that a subcommittee of
the health and human services oversight
committee if we need one is an option
but i don't think we need to study this
issue it's woefully underfunded we ought
to fund it more there are funds
available from there are funds
in that we get a tobacco settlement but
that money gets allocated to other
things by our budget writers so that's
the problem and i don't think that
having a committee or a commission or a
subcommittee to study it actually gets
us a lot farther forward what we need to
do is get
the money put into the budget
thank you
someone else has a hand up that looks
yes and um
well
sitting here uh
sorting out what we're doing i i
i sort of even misheard what the issue
is about how much money we spend but
just to clarify i did quickly look it up
for
the uh tobacco
education and so on in new hampshire in
the fiscal year 2019
that though we took in
255 million dollars in tobacco
settlement and taxes we only allocated
140 000
to prevention which is the 0.8 of the
cdc
number as opposed to the 15 which would
be a bare minimum so i agree with
representative weber we don't need to
think about it we just need to have the
will to do it to realize that some of
this money needs to go fund
cessation not just to fund all the other
no
unmute
we're not that good at reading your lips
yeah
i thought you're gonna interpret that
thank you i'm sorry my my computer
automatically unmutes me from time to
time but anyway
can you hear me now yeah yes thank you
i had the same question that
representative canerck had but i just
wondered if there was anything anywhere
that had a percentage of that money that
in this in the tobacco fund that's
supposed to be spent on prevention is
there a percentage somebody said 15
hello
representative
yeah it was what they were referring to
was 15 of a spending target from the cdc
it's not
uh at least the information i've dug up
it doesn't have a percentage of what
we're supposed to be using within the
state but we know that the state
chronically does these things i mean
think about the meals and rooms tax
it's it's not returned back to the
municipalities the way it should
this is not being put into tobacco
cessation
as it should
and
those individuals on the committee
follow up those individuals
are they in as good a position as anyone
to look at this situation and ask if the
percentage of those funds that are spent
on prevention
is adequate i mean i don't know we need
a new committee
to do that i think the oversight
committee can handle this and we will
ask people to testify before us and so
on
thank you anybody else
emotion before us
moved itl by representative soloway and
seconded by representative mckay
if you vote yes or i you are voting itl
the clerk please call the world
thank you mr chair
representative marsh
yes
representative mcmahon
representative nelson
yes
representative acton
representative gay
yes
representative cushman
representative folsom yes representative
melvin
yes
representative king
representative cole fault
yes
representative weber yes
representative mckay
yes
representative snow
representative knurk
yes
representative soloway
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yeah
representative woods
yes
representative merchant
and representative pearson yes
21 to 0.
without consent
to consent representative soloway please
yes
please write the blurb
i will
i will try to get that done how do i
convey that to you mr chair by email
that's a very acceptable practice okay
thank you
and with that we close the executive
session on how house bill
and in our schedule and only
40 minutes late
is house bill 381
relative to laboratory testing
and representative edwards is recognized
to introduce his bill
ah
okay so i'm off of mute i don't know if
you can see me uh if you can it's
unfortunate i put a coat and tie on
uh i'm uh i'm representative jess
edwards i represent uh auburn
chester and stand down
house bill 381 fn is
essentially identical to the bill that
was heard last term by this committee
the the difference was last term
we had a bill in an amendment to go with
it to improve it
and this bill is fully integrated so
it's just one bill no amendment uh what
it does is essentially establishes or or
advances it doesn't establish but it
advances the principle
uh that
individuals should be able to get
information about their own medical
conditions
and that they should be able to do that
in a
most efficient least or least expensive
way possible
the bill would allow an individual adult
to go in
and order a diagnostic pathology
procedure
and uh and receive it if the pathology
service
chooses to provide the service
the pathology services are not mandated
under this bill they're enabled to do a
direct diagnostic pathology test
at the patient's own
personal request
the
patient is required under this bill to
pay for it themselves when they're
ordering it themselves
so there's more personal accountability
there
the pathology service
needs to be nationally certified uh
which was an important part of the
amendment last year that's now in the
bill
um
and then
the the physicians
that may
have this person as a patient
they're not held liable for anything
resulting in their diagnos diagnosis and
treatment unless they are aware of the
of the laboratory procedure
so um this bill would have helped me in
a narrow instance and so i think it's
going to help others
i i went naked without health insurance
leaving my corporate job before i
got into the age category where the va
provided me care so there were about
nine months there where i knew that i
had
type 2 diabetes and then i wanted to get
an a1c
uh i i knew how to interpret the number
of an a1c it's not really rocket science
uh
six or thereabouts is kind of okay
the double digits you got a real problem
so
um so so it would help to me but um
i
when i went in to ask one of the local
labs they they said they weren't
authorized without a physician's order
now that might have been policy
but but what i'm suggesting is that this
bill
would uh emulate what arizona has done
for three or four years now
there doesn't seem to be any problems in
arizona with it and i would ask that we
advance this very small medical freedom
bill
free market bill
in new hampshire and if you're
you're concerned about the physician
outside of the loop and i would just
remind you that increasingly we have
wearable diagnostics
that are taking all kinds of diagnostic
information and allowing us to to look
at them
ourselves
and
that medical information
is not necessarily integrated with your
medical record so
we already have a situation where the
technology
is getting out in front of our brick and
mortar system
and and what this bill would do would be
to allow our brick and mortar
laboratories to basically
keep pace with
the evolving nature of our health care
system
so with that i'd ask you to
consider this bill and offer it up as a
otp and i'll take questions if there are
any and we'll call on people to ask you
questions in just a minute but i'm
moving ahead dr
gary sobelson from the new hampshire
medical society because he has told me
he has patience imminently so if dr
sobelson you're still on the meeting and
wish to testify
i am and thank you very much for that uh
opportunity can you can you hear me uh
chairman
am i being heard you are being heard and
and thank you
um
thank you very much mr chairman and
representatives uh thank you for this
opportunity to present my testimony
regarding hb 381
my name is dr gary sobelson and i'm a
family physician in concord
i come here though representing the new
hampshire medical society
and we do wish to speak against passage
of this bill
um hb 381 exposes the challenge of
maintaining scientific professionalism
in an increasing consumer-driven society
i think the uh the
representative who just presented this
bill absolutely
presented that case
its goal to increase access to
laboratory medicine is very tempting and
attempts to open up a broad area of
medical practice
previously limited by what are almost
centuries-old constraints certainly more
recent
somewhat like the effect of dr google
with regard to medical knowledge
would suggest that individuals can
successfully manage their own medical
affairs and should have the freedom to
do so
but the new hampshire medical society
would suggest that hb 381
is a pandora's box and we would
encourage the new hampshire legislature
not open this box at this time
the ordering of laboratory tests is a
very complex and essential component of
the practice of medicine
as opposed to the simplicity that the
prior representative just presented with
regard to a test that in fact might be a
good one to have available
much is not simple in laboratory
medicine but it's actually not for that
reason that we traditional reason that
we oppose the bill
it's really because profound educational
quality monitoring and yes even with the
bills line
liability bearing responsibilities are
closely tied to this decision making
in order to effectively order laboratory
tests a medical professional is required
to understand the pathophysiology behind
them the rationale of the test use
perform risk benefit and cost benefit
analysis
and consider the proper use and
consequences of creating medical data
ordering and interpreting most medical
tests requires understanding
of test sensitivity and specificity
positive and negative predictive value
and similar concepts um stuff that a lot
of americans have become a little bit
familiar with listening to uh covet test
results over the past year but for what
we would argue is a very complex set of
decision making for a
very very large number of tests and most
importantly it requires that all our
clinicians take responsibility for
interpreting the meaning of those
results within the context
of a specific patient's medical needs
now again an individual may say that
they're the ultimate owner of those
needs but but that's not something that
applies to every piece of data about
them the efforts of this bill to gloss
over those elements with statutory
language do not persuade our profession
of that wisdom
unnecessary tests lead to unnecessary
care is a well-grained maxim in that in
the education of a doctor or a pa or a
nurse practitioner
more is not better than the area
diagnostic testing and in fact it comes
with measurable and significant risks
that we study and discuss in our
literature and they become our
responsibility to understand and
practice
ultimately the issue of medical
liability will be settled by the
judiciary and despite the earnest
efforts of a section in this bill
section 4 to relieve clinicians of
liability stemming from actions proposed
by the bill
i would suggest to you that our society
would support that the downstream
ramifications are impossible to predict
while hb 381 tries to dissect off
insurance building
billing and therefore increased medical
costs from its goals there is no
question to me as a clinician that one
of the first outcomes of data being
presented to me that i didn't ask for
is is that i'm going to repeat the test
it's done throughout our medical system
we see it all the time or even worse
perform expensive follow-up studies that
weren't needed in the first place but
now they're required for liability and
defensive medicine purposes this is
already a very significant issue in
medical practice and an awful lot of our
medical resources go to evaluate what we
call incidental omas
things that are identified on a lab
panel or a diagnostic test but they're
overwhelmingly unlikely to be important
to a patient's health
this patient is really hard this problem
by the way is very hard to address even
in its current form but legislation like
the one in front of you will undoubtedly
expand such practices and therefore will
have significant cost ramifications to
programs like new hampshire medicaid
insurance companies and ultimately to
all of us
the fda has a robust and coherent
program for assessing and approving
direct to consumer testing there's home
testing kits and mail-in systems that
address many of the goals of this
legislation and this should be the path
by which medical testing becomes
consumer friendly and accessible
such important home tests that we all
are used to pregnancy testing ovulation
testing blood sugar testing hiv testing
and recently approved coven 19 testing
have been approved
after they are scrutinized for accuracy
for narrowness of purpose usefulness to
the public and with consideration to
their advantages and dangers
a bill like hb 381 that
broadly opens up medical laboratory
testing meets none of those criteria in
our view
to conclude one can purchase a scalpel
and you can use it to cut balsa wood or
create beautiful works of art but we do
not legislate opening up the operating
rooms of our state hospitals to anyone
who can wield a knife
similarly while the safety of many
over-the-counter products has increased
access and reduced costs to allergy
medications minor pain relievers and
low-cost steroid low-potency steroid
greens through a rigorous fda assessment
program about the value and safety of
each product
the american health system has chosen
not to let consumer demand define access
to opioids systemic antibiotics and many
high potency prescription medications
understanding that the same principles
presented here require that the control
of such products through statute and law
are preferred to the temptation of
absolute freedom because of the dangers
both obvious and inadvertent may ensue
the new hampshire medical society with
over 2 000 physician members request
that you consider the obvious and
unintended consequences of hb 381 and
vote to defeat its purposes
thank you
would you take some questions doctor
i can for a few moments yes
okay any questions for the doctor
because he's got a run
uh okay somebody who just waved an index
finger
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman and thank you dr
sobelson for taking my question it's a
pleasure uh hearing you again today
would i not be correct that there are
already a number of sites across the
state of new hampshire where consumers
can go and order their laboratory tests
without a doctor's order have them
shipped to laboratories in the state of
arizona
and have them perform
and so therefore the only effect of this
bill will be to allow new hampshire
laboratories to compete on a level
playing field with laboratories in the
state of arizona
i representative marsh dr marsh i am not
familiar with such labs um i have no
doubt that there are different states
with different laws
um my my comment is really about what
new hampshire law and new azure stats
should should propose i do not know of
what you speak
and
representative
merchant
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
for taking my question dr sobel son
following up on dr marsha's website
marsha's question
i'm aware of the fact i think even in
vermont next door
that they allow for a lot of the testing
we're talking about prohibiting here in
new hampshire
i think there's 37 states that now
currently allow for it so i don't know
dr sorensen
i i don't i mean i thought
representative merchant i thought that
was a comment
i understand the basis but was there a
question i didn't hear a question
just giving you a chance in case you
wanted to respond
again
yeah
i think my testimony stands on that
comment that's fine
you know again i think there is i would
i would expound that there is increasing
consumerism there is certainly increased
access to testing but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's a good thing
and that we should widely open it up in
our state just because it happens in
other places
thank you i guess
yes uh
representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you dr
sobelson for taking my question
uh let's assume um a patient has gone to
a direct to consumer
lab uh got a lab study and it's uh uh
determined by the patient this is
abnormal
and they send it to your office
although the bill
uh as identified that you're not
culpable
for acting on that once it reaches your
office
my understanding is that once you're
made aware of it you are indeed culpable
is that your understanding
um
absolutely correct uh representative dr
woods i i i think as we well know our
responsibilities are um there
are different levels of this but
information and that is within our
knowledge but we have we have a direct
responsibility for the patient ignoring
data that comes into us that we see
would be professionally unresponsible i
think our board of medicine would frown
very strongly on that it would frankly
be unethical um beyond whatever
the legislature tries to state now
whether what type of evidence is
available in a court of law is way
outside of my purview but but the most
important point about this is that the
kind of tests that we're talking about
are the beginning point of what is often
of
much more information so the example of
the a1c but which by the way i would
support an a1c being available to a to a
diabetic uh to know that i don't think
there's very high risk there at all but
the point is the a1c comes if i don't
respond to it um and i don't contact the
patient and say i see that you have an
a1c of 10 and therefore your diabetes is
important what are we going to do about
that
i would certainly be seen as liable and
under
our current standards of care
so
i don't see how the legislature can
protect against information
not being available as evidence perhaps
in malpractice but what about the
representative gay thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question
if you do receive a no
a test result
say an a1c of 10 instead of 7
below 7
what is the problem
if this is your patient
and now you know
and you can charge it's not a problem
about charging telemedicine what is the
problem
well i i think we're we're picking the
example that is probably the best
example of something that might be a
good test to segment out and have
i'm available to diabetics much as home
blood sugar testing by the way is but
how about if a patient orders um a
genetic uh panel
that uh identity that that identifies
him as having you know being at risk for
a rare illness
um now again there are companies that
are that are doing that but
does so now that information comes to me
what what is my responsibility now what
if i don't even have the expertise to
interpret that test
um and again i i think the the there are
many many laboratory tests that even i
as a family physician don't have the
expertise to order and i shouldn't be
working
so i think i think by picking the
examples of things that perhaps there
will be marketable tests in uh simple to
interpret safe reliable
um understandable tests
and then opening that up to a blood
panel which has 26
values on it um almost always
statistically people have slide errors
on and now call me up
to want to know what it all means well
it doesn't mean anything um you know do
i do i need a workup for my liver
disease because my transaminase test was
36 when the normal on this lab is 34.
so it's really not a matter of charges
it's a matter of doing unnecessary tests
that lead to more unnecessary tests
that's our greatest concern as a
exciting
representative
thank you thank you dr sobelson i wanted
to get back to that issue of the
what we do see with that diagnostic
cascade and particularly with the
risks of
screening tests which have may have a
high false positivity rate or poor
predictive value or serology tests where
the implications aren't really what they
might appear at first glance
so do you think if we were going to pass
such a bill as this
um i mean well i should say given the
fact that you know we go through four
years of college four years of medical
school three to six years of residency
so we can interpret these do you think
the patient with the assistance of dr
google will have the ability to be able
to sort these issues out themselves and
should there be a disclaimer by the lab
if such a bill went through
to emphasize what the importance is the
false negativity of any given test or
its poor predictive value
yeah i mean i i think i think your your
preamble explains the problem that that
the
concept that this is in any way a simple
and straightforward aspect of medical
practice is a fallacy
so um this is this is no this is far
more challenging than the decision to
prescribe antibiotics and yet we don't
have people walking into pharmacies and
getting antibiotics it's far more
challenging than a great deal of the
simple decision making that goes on in
medicine it's actually one of the most
complex aspects of decision making that
we do is deciding what tests to order
and then deciding what to do with that
information
i'm not sure a disclaimer takes me very
far uh representative
but uh um i i suspect that
again those those are the lawyers lining
up to sort of determine liability in in
a certain very basic way my greater
concern is what it says to our society
on uh about
the their their role in health care um
versus
how important education becomes you know
and again i think this reference to dr
google is a good one um i think in our
current in our current state withholding
knowledge is a
is not something that we really want to
do on the other hand we really want
people to be careful about how they use
that knowledge and and this is an area
where the state has some control
obviously we can't control um the the
misinformation that comes across the
internet that at times puts people at
risk but maybe we can control them not
ordering their own tests and trying to
representative cushman
thank you
thank you mr chairman
um
my question is
what is to stop um physicians if their
patient orders gets tests ordered
through
um a lab without the physician's order
what is to stop the physician from
explaining to the patient when the
patient makes them aware of the results
of this
i don't have the expertise for that and
then referring them or
just simply explaining
well this is what i know about the
specificity of this test
and
is there something that will prevent a
absolutely not i think physicians could
make their own determination if if you
pass a bill of this sort uh the medical
system will have to find a way to adapt
to
um a consumer-driven testing model i
guess i mean we and we will do so um you
know we're not going to abandon our
patients uh just because they come at us
with data um i guess what i what our
society is trying to say to you all is
that this is not going to enhance the
care of this of the of the citizens of
new hampshire it's probably going to
increase the risk of increased cost and
an adverse outcome
following
um well what what do you think about
um so many cases that we hear about that
i see as a nurse and
also um where patients ask
and and bring a problem to their
physician and ask for you know what
should be done
and only to be
uh have their issue minimized and say oh
well it's nothing
and then the patient goes and luckily we
have
the world's information at our
fingertips and the patient finds
something to go off of and goes to a
different doctor and says can you order
this lab
and or or goes to an independent lab
that is serviced through another state
and then they find that they they are
they do have a diagnosis that was missed
by the doctor
don't you think that this bill could
help solve some of those
misdiagnoses
um respectfully i suspect that that
problem is a is an unusual problem but
you
you've also described how it often gets
solved is that people make the decision
to seek other expertise um they
generally don't solve the problem by
ordering their own test
um and and as what i tried to point out
in my testimony was that i think the the
greater risk of this is that you'll have
more misdiagnosis
um so that
again increasing access to some sorts of
data by people who are not trained to
interpret that data that being the
general citizenry um could probably
increase the risk i mean i suspect there
are people who who uh
you know uh
i mean we don't let people without
driver's license drive i suspect
sometimes they could avert
uh you know bad something bad happens to
them if they could drive somewhere but
we're recognizing the
that there are risks associated with
those limited benefits and uh and i and
i think the benefits are quite limited
in the in the situation when you're
describing
click
representative
somewhere
thank you chairman and thank you very
much um dr sobelson for taking my time
turn your
screen off for a second so they don't
see me you're hearing
voices
can hear your voices
could everybody
um
anyway to go ahead um
if we have people who are
uh getting tests and then sending them
to the doctor who then needs to either
retest further test or
refer to other folks for
confirmation that this is not in fact an
issue that is of true concern uh does
that risk driving up the cost of medical
insurance for the general population
i i i believe that that was my st one of
my comments uh because i saw in this
bill it did not seem to have a fiscal
note attached to it um i believe it does
and there are examples of that already
um now there's a
program called lifeline that many of you
probably have gotten the mailings from
now this is not patient driven this is
actually a medical there are doctors
behind that project but they're not your
doctors and their doctor is making a
profit but but they order tests
and then the lifeline report comes to me
and i'll tell you that when you test a
lot of
people over the age of 60 looking for
let's say carotid disease
um a a a disease state which the uh that
expert groups in the united states have
said you should not be screening people
for that that that early early disease
inter finding early disease is
not valuable well lifeline finds this
all the time and now a patient comes to
me and says you know i've got a they
tell me i may have a blockage of my
carotid you better do some additional
tests now not only does that does that
lead to very expensive follow-up testing
it leads to testing that puts your life
at risk
and and in fact the expert groups that
have studied this have said that we
shouldn't that those tests shouldn't
have been done in the first place and
the only way to avoid that so that's an
example now again the average person
looks at that and says well if i have
early carotid disease i'd sure like to
know because maybe it'll stop me from
having a stroke
well the trouble is that the
interventions that we're going to follow
through from that test might be of
greater risk to you than the benefit and
in fact that's the evidence
it's not this is the more is not better
question in american medicine and
and those of us who practice preventive
medicine are in the system have really
come to understand that
and again
the kind of data we're talking about
creating with this bill will contribute
to that will contribute to the cost but
also will contribute significantly to
risk
thank you
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman and thank you dr
sobelson
um
in regards to the laboratory work we've
been talking about diagnostic work
a lot of the lab work that i've seen has
been more to monitor a clinical outcome
or improvement and so forth not strictly
to diagnose the patient so what i'm
trying to ask a question to you is is
there a reasonable compromise here
saying that if the patient's been
diagnosed and has a diagnosis
whether it be diabetes and so forth that
they could in fact order
a1c or some other
lab work that's going to help them
monitor their therapy and achieve the
outcome the clinician wants them to
achieve it doesn't have to do with
diagnosing an issue but monitoring a
clinical outcome or trying to get to an
outcome would that be a reasonable
compromise
again i think that comes back in my
testimony representative merchant to the
idea of being specific and limited its
scope so your example of an a1c is a
good one i mean
frankly i'm i'm surprised there isn't a
commercial home test for a1c there
probably should be it may be that it's
harder to perform
than i'm guessing because that would be
a good example of a limited focus very
useful test for someone to be able to
monitor on their own much as people do
their own blood sugars the trouble with
just talking about monitoring a
diagnosis is that again it opens up a
very deep pandora's box of diagnosis
if i have lymphoma should i be able to
monitor my cbc's and monitor my my blood
work
if i'm on chemotherapy um or if i'm not
on chemotherapy um i don't know if i
have lupus should i be able to monitor
the very complex
medical tests that are available to
people like that so i think that's where
you have to kind of go to standards of
care
by specialists in in particular groups
and and it's why in fact many of us
support um consumer-driven approaches in
diagnosis like diabetes but probably
wouldn't when it comes to cancer
um you're dealing with an entirely
different scope of testing and so i
think your compromise again speaks to
the importance of having limited testing
that's thought about and that's what the
fda does
with this with with a lot because
there's a great deal of commercial
interest in what you're talking about
but i i don't see how you can manage
that with regard to routine laboratories
pathologies
specimens and blood work in our in our
side
mr chairman let me follow up please
follow up yes thank you dr simpleton
um
give an example of something it doesn't
do with blood sugar but
i have a family member who has to go to
a position to
basically get a potassium level done
um
right now it's an inconvenience they
know it but every single time they want
it done they have to go to the lab
by the position
and what i get to is there's
it's not just a1c this cholesterol is
other
lab tests that can be done
that are i think open to helping the
patient would we should be trying to
teach the patient to manage the care
and not constantly go back to themselves
it goes back to the analogy to teach
somebody how to fish versus fishing for
them and i'm trying to get that fine
line and saying how do we help the
patient become a caregiver of their own
care versus everything having to go
through the physician because not
everything has to go through the
physician sure to go through the
position and i'm trying to find that
middle ground and saying how do we help
the patient care for themselves
again i i'd respond representative
merchant very respectfully i agree with
great deal the philosophy you're
bringing forth but the example's
a good one so a serum potassium
a seemingly simple test is an extremely
complex bit of pathophysiology is it
renal is it is it medication problems is
it because um is it nutritional so um so
that is a test that has no standard for
following it you have to know what
you're following um and again
a patient shouldn't be self-managing
their potassium there's way too much
knowledge and and i think what you're
describing
um i think very virtuously is that there
are conditions that patients can do a
lot of self-management on and in those
situations we should find ways to make
it as inexpensive and easy for them
to do that and i fully support that but
i don't think this bill really does that
i think this bill kind of opens up a
wide a wide array and i'm not sure how
you can narrow it down without being
very specific about specific tests and
that's and that's i guess where i would
end my and my thoughts about that um i
think we could
agree about a few additional specific
tests but i don't think that we would
agree that a electrolytes or serum
potassium would be a good choice
we would say that takes an awful lot of
representative nelson
yes
yes chairman thank you for taking this
question if somebody just watch goes
into a lab in a hospital
and they want a certain test
for free
i'm not an expert in this area but i'm
pretty sure i could say no to that one
but on two fronts one is i don't think
you could walk into a hospital lab and
order your own test
any hospital in our state and secondly
i'm pretty sure
you can
representative snow
yes
thank you uh mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question dr sobel said
wouldn't it be smarter if
looking at the bill lines 16 through 20
it really says
the physician is no risk no obligation
to respond to laboratory tests that he
didn't order and that they have no
uh
not subject to any liability a
disorder if they do but if people
did have a relationship with a physician
such as yourself
can't they request
routine i i get uh coumadin levels tests
whatever they call that test
and i get a year-long order from a lab i
go down with the intervals that they
want to go to and the insurance then
pays for it however if i went had those
tests done on my own i'd have to pour it
out of pocket each time i did it
wouldn't it wouldn't this
responsibility if somebody goes on their
own it would bring on unnecessary costs
they could be avoided by simply having a
responsible relationship with a
physician that could order tests
periodically without necessarily having
another appointment
the
doctor's office just calls me back and
says your level is fine do the same
thing next month
uh
wouldn't that be a much smarter move and
we makes this
bill sort of unnecessary except in very
unusual circumstances such as what uh
representative edwards talked about
where they just didn't have a
relationship with a physician
i mean isn't isn't this
only necessary in the most
well i i would i would agree with
everything you said representatives know
so i agree and i think your example of
how physicians try to make testing
accessible and low cost is is part of
the point
i don't think that's the intent of this
legislation the intent of this
legislation is i think as as presented
is to in fact bypass physician and nurse
practitioner and pa
control over this and make it a consumer
activity
and again
i i don't think that's without some
potential benefit but i don't think as
widely open as discussed that that's all
so i agree with you that's that's how we
do things and in fact the the economic
aspect of it is actually in my mind a
very minimal aspect of this um
as you described um you know we we don't
we don't charge you know there are many
patients of mine who who get an a1c and
call three months later and we review it
together and uh it's a standing order
and you know and you just and you manage
them over the phone because you know
they don't have insurance and you know
it's but but that doesn't change my
responsibility whether i'm charging them
or not i still have the same level of
responsibility to provide care that
meets the standard of care and that's
excellent and
and i think that's where this this bill
particularly i'll finish it suggest that
okay
a doctor so
my note here says you have patience at
11 30 and i i am i
thank you
welcome
um i'm going to call a couple more
people to testify
um
apparently there's been a windstorm in
auburn and
representative edwards is uh
not on the internet is he here by
telephone
well there's another storm um i'm i'm
i'm back okay okay he's there okay
you're back and now we're back
uh to
questions for you from the committee
okay
sorry i missed so much of uh
the previous witnesses answers they were
pretty interesting to me
anyone with any questions um i see a
hand
that looks like representative bill
nelson
thank you very much um
it may have been during your absence of
representative edwards we did talk a lot
about the diagnostic cascade where one
test leads to another and often if there
is something that's inconclusive a lab
may say we would suggest that you would
proceed on with this this and this
be given the the fact that there would
be a motivation of the lab to encourage
more business would you be if we did
pass this bill would you be amenable to
an amendment that would prohibit a
laboratory from suggesting any further
so thank you for your question um
i think i think that's a very
interesting possibility
uh i would i would want to talk to
people that i know um
in arizona about
an an effective amendment might like
have like that and they've tried
something like that
i think somebody's pounding some pots
and pans in the kitchen somewhere
but uh would you say in any case stop
pounding pots and pans go ahead
so um
but to answer your question directly i'm
i'm amenable to any amendment that
that the this committee wants to offer i
would like to
[Music]
enjoy the fact that some of you may
share with me the principle of
empowering patients
and and allowing them to gain access to
their own medical information so that
they
can uh do with it what they think they
should do whether that's go find a
physician or or just eat more healthy or
whatever i
i do like the medical freedom aspect of
this bill and as much as and i'll stop
there because that's all you ask
representative edwards um
given you mentioned the word amendment
my plan is to exec this bill next monday
so anybody who wishes to bring forth
amendments would be very helpful if we
could see them by the end of the week so
that we wouldn't go right into monday
and have to stop and read them at that
time so
that's the plan i have going forward
um let's see uh represented
you had your hand up yes
thank you mr chair and
thank you representative edwards
uh about two years ago i
i wanted to get my cholesterol checked
it's been many years before i got
checked
uh since i got a check so i
uh called my tcp
uh he had left the practice so i could
set up another exam another
appointment
and it was six months before he was
available
i went to that appointment and he gave
me an order to go get uh some testing
and i started a new job got
distracted and by the time i got to the
uh to go get the testing the order had
expired and i had to go at that point i
threw my hands up and i still haven't
gotten my cross broadcast so would your
would this feel healthy in that
situation
i i thank you for the question
representative acton and i'd say this
bill would uh have addressed directly
your issue
you you were it sounds like you were in
between providers
you you knew that you had a chronic
condition you knew
that you needed a particular cholesterol
test
uh you knew that based on the results uh
what you might do to modify your
behavior to to better manage your health
status
uh
this bill would have allowed you
to be an empowered respected member of
society
able to access your own information and
and to behave responsibly in your own
self-interest so i think this bill would
have helped you yes sir thank you
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative edwards
um
i realized that you didn't hear all of
the previous testimony but some of it um
leading to over testing which might be
might be medically problematic and also
financially problematic
the difficulty in interpreting many
tests
um
i am very sympathetic to patient
autonomy and people being able to take
control of their own bodies and their
own health
but i'm concerned about the
complications some of the unintended
complications that
um
you know broad opening of testing might
cause so would you be amenable
amending this bill so that it
um allowed for certain types of testing
that were determined to be
more useful and
tested did not lead to unintended bad
consequences
um
that might take retaining the bill
because i think this would be a
complicated um
amendment to make we need a lot of
expertise to know which tests should be
included and which should be um not
included but would you be open to that
approach
so the short answers um uh yes but um i
i would just as a fellow legislator
suggest to you
that um
that
that that's probably uh too much detail
for a policy committee to try to
research and legislate and put into
statute
that it might be better to identify
some some panel that already exists
somewhere and have them
issued
able to issue guidance on on which labs
should be able to be ordered and which
shouldn't
keep in mind my bill does not mandate
that the laboratories do the testing so
i
i do think i've left some flexibility in
there for
labs and pathologists just simply say no
uh it's a it's a voluntary
uh interaction between labs and in
people
so um so i
i i just would suggest a different
approach but i'm open to
an amendment if that's what the
any further questions for representative
edwards representative gay
thank you mr chairman and thank you um
for taking my question
do you agree
i'm trying to
do you agree that this bill is a
compromise for people who don't have
insurance
and need to do this
without paying for a physician
either because you can't
reach position or they just can't afford
it
and people who do have insurance you've
identified
you
you've identified the exact sweet spot
for this bill
that that individual that sentient adult
who is in between health care providers
and maybe be short on funds but knows
that they need to know something about
their health status that a diagnostic
pathology exam might reveal
and so
that would be
a key segment of our
adult population that would benefit from
this bill those without
providers
follow-up
the other condition i mean that is
you know i agree
absolutely
and the
i found myself in a position it wasn't a
lab test
it was um
i had to see three
uh
three spinal surgeons before i found one
who agreed with the doctor who read my
mri
and so i'm very sympathetic to this
situation because
it sounds like this would also
uh put this as a question wouldn't this
also help a person who has insurance
and can't find a doctor who is agreeing
with their symptoms so that this way
what's their
what
their problem is that nobody's listening
to yet
so i'm thinking it benefits more i don't
know how to put that question but don't
you think that helps benefits people who
have insurance too as well as the people
i i think any uh thank you for the
question i i think that anytime
you empower a patient to take care of
themselves and to worry about their own
health status
you're making the health care system
that much better i
i i heard the theory
of of cascade diagnostic procedures and
potential increases to the health
insurance system
but i would just uh
remind folks that this this is not a new
law it's been done in arizona we could
find out if this cascade problem has
been a problem but my bill explicitly
states
that insurance companies do not have to
pay for the procedure
that's an individual
responsibility of the the person who who
wants to know more about their health
condition
so so the rest i think is theory and um
and a valid concern
but i wouldn't kill this bill out of
theory and concerns that haven't been
validated
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative edwards um
i was wondering are you aware that there
are some conditions that um
that
patients feel symptoms for a long time
before they they become clinical
so
to the question about amending the bill
this could potentially
uh be a disservice to people
experiencing some of those conditions if
they're they're checking their labs and
they they have you know they're really
trying to get to the bottom of their
symptoms to stop them from
repeat labs
that are negative at first
so i don't thank you for the question i
i don't want to overstate my credentials
i'm i'm i'm merely a health care manager
with over 40 years in the industry doing
a range
range of different things i'm not
the closest i've come to being a
pathologist was carrying urine specimens
from the er to the lab so i don't think
that qualified me uh i did learn how to
wash my hands though
um but but
so i
i defer to this committee because this
committee could be its own medical board
with all the diversity on it
to to make those determinations i'm i'm
bringing it to the committee saying
here's a small way
that we could allow our brick and mortar
industry to keep up with what's going on
in the medical
wearable diagnostic industry um and
uh and it's a medical freedom bill from
my perspective so so i'm coming at it
from sort of um you know who who
controls your body
as much as i i respect of the physician
community for
taking ownership and accountability uh
and and citing potential uh health
economics
uh issues with this bill
i
i think
i start from the perspective of saying
in our society
the individual has a tremendous respect
from its government from its from from
and hopefully from its
institutions to to be allowed
to
live in a way in which they exercise
choice and so this is a this is i don't
know it's kind of a pro-choice my body
my choice kind of bill
i know that offends some people to to
borrow that phrase but but but it is so
um i i didn't answer your question other
than to speak a lot and say i don't know
i see representative merchants hand up
thank you mr chairman thank you
represent edwards for taking my question
um we've heard throughout this um
testimony about the issue about cost
and also over testing and so forth my
understanding in the bill
under lines 22 23 and 24
that there's no cost to the insurance
company this is out of pocket to the
patient
so in essence because the cost of lab
tests being what they are today is that
sort of a self-regulating
step in a sense that
patients aren't going to over do a lot
of testing if they have to pay for
out-of-pocket they have the privilege to
do it but the reality is because of the
cost situation most likely they're not
thank you for the question and yes i'm a
proponent of the pricing mechanism and
how the pricing mechanism disciplines
both supply and demand and makes people
come to rational choices so yes
thank you
i'm going to be running a test
representative soloway's computer audio
is not working so he's got video on his
screen and is picking up audio on his
phone the question is can we hear him so
can you hear me
pass the test
i see no further hands
for
representative edwards so
thank you for your testimony
uh thank you very much and i don't know
if there's anyone else uh testifying
after this but i'll
stick around there are there's a few who
signed up
thank you man thank you so much
you can sort of listen in if you want um
next is
mr elliot axelman who identifies himself
as a member of the public and he wishes
to testify
in support of this bill mr elliott
excellent
it doesn't appear to be on the attendees
list
okay thank you
michelle half who's from the new
hampshire
naturopathic association
and
she says on here she is neutral on this
bill but would still like to give us
i'm not seeing her as well mr chair
and last on the list is dr douglas
phelan amen sorry
i'm sorry do we do we have
we have dr half hold on please wonderful
thank you
dr half
yes thank you so much mr chair and
members of the committee for hearing my
testimony today
my name is dr michelle haff i am a new
hampshire licensed naturopathic doctor
in bedford new hampshire
and today i'm representing the new
hampshire association of naturopathic
doctors
we're a professional membership
organization that represents 150
naturopathic doctors licensed in new
hampshire
this year marks 25 years that we've been
licensed and during that time we've seen
significant growth in our profession and
public interest in our services
so our association has concerns that
this bill is its currently proposed um
defines a licensed medical practitioner
as a physician
an advanced practice nurse practitioner
or a physician assistant
failure to list new hampshire licensed
naturopathic doctors as licensed medical
practitioners in item one of this bill
is actually in direct conflict with the
naturopathic healthcare practice law
which is rsa 328e
which passed in 1995.
this law specifically authorizes
naturopathic doctors to order and
interpret lab tests
and this aspect of our scope of practice
is consistent with our professional
medical training where all licensees
have attended a four-year medical
education program at an accredited
university or accredited institution
uh with specific and extensive training
in this diagnostic tool
um so we're requesting that item one be
amended to include
a naturopathic doctor licensed under rsa
328e as a licensed medical practitioner
and just to speak to our kind of stance
on this bill
we would gladly support it if we are
included in it
we do have mixed feelings about patients
self-ordering tests
but this practice has been in place for
quite a while
mainly by uninsured folks as others have
pointed out um we actually like item
three of this bill
which
says that if if an unlicensed medical
provider comes in contact with with
these lab results they would need to
refer to a licensed medical provider
um i think of the countless people who
are ordering their own labs and
interpreting them and i think that this
would actually
lead to
to
better health outcomes for the people of
new hampshire
and some of the the more
obscure labs that people are ordering
such as diagnosis
general
genetic testing
and food sensitivity testing or salivary
hormone panels um that people are
self-ordering we actually have a lot of
experience interpreting those
um and so we think it would you know
provide better quality of care for the
citizens of new hampshire
so thank you for your time i'm happy to
representative gay could you please
spell
naturopathic
sure um it's n a t
as in tom u r o
seeing no further questions we thank you
dr half for your testimony
and the final one i have on the list is
dr douglas phelan
from the new hampshire academy of family
physicians
hi good morning uh good morning mr
chairman and honorable representatives
my name is doug phelan i'm a family
medicine physician practicing as well in
bedford new hampshire
and i am present today on behalf of the
new hampshire academy of family
physicians and myself
speaking in opposition to hb 381
so many of you are already aware that in
the united states we spend far and away
the most money per capita on health care
nearly eleven thousand dollars per
citizen and yet amongst comparable
nations in the oecd we have the lowest
life expectancy the fifth highest
maternal mortality the highest chronic
disease burden and i could go on
we've got work to do and we know it
but i think this shows we can spend
money all we want but it's not getting
us to the goal it's not getting us to
health
so why bring this bill this up in a bill
regarding direct access testing or dat
because if we want to improve our health
outcomes and spend less while doing so
um what we don't necessarily want to do
and is have open access for any lab test
in a catalog
just because somebody has the money to
pay for it
more testing does not equal more health
and
i think we would say that if you think
that unfettered dat is beneficial if you
truly believe in your heart of hearts
that it is
then
you tend not to make as in sections in
five and six do
uh with regards to insurance so that
only those with the money to get the
tests have the access
so we would posit
generally that the bill is not in the
sum of its parts going to promote health
but if you disagree with that and feel
that it does we would also posit that it
would then exacerbate health inequities
for our patients
when it comes to resource utilization
how has the covid19 pandemic driven home
the importance of resource utilization
how long did it take us to switch
production mechanisms to make sure that
we had enough lab supplies enough vials
swabs reagents to run tests i can
remember a time in the spring where due
to coded testing requirements we were
asked not to run certain types of
sexually transmitted disease tests
because they used the same supplies that
were needed for coded testing this is
not a hypothetical
health care is not immune to the laws of
economics and laboratory studies are one
example of the struggle between finite
resources and infinite wants and needs
we set policies to make sure that the
resources are allocated appropriately
so to do as part two of the bill
indicates mandating that a person may
directly obtain any study from any
licensed laboratory without a medical
provider we feel that would open up our
state to the depletion of scarce
resources
you know we we do not have to imagine a
world where depletion of lab resources
both physical and human might lead to
lag times and availability issues we've
just been living through it
when it comes to provider responsibility
part 4 seeks to exonerate medical
providers from reviewing or acting upon
by compulsion the the dat results and
removing liability and disciplinary
action
we feel this creates a precarious
situation
for example a patient with a recent
chest pain having investigated what
blood tests might be ordered for
somebody with chest pain they come
across the troponin test and they order
it
and to some extent it's elevated but
they're feeling okay at the moment and
they seek management with their primary
care office
this bill seems to as written make me
upon hearing it not necessarily liable
to treat
this of course is not a tenable option
medical providers once evaluating
information on a patient must consider
it
first out of our oath and caring for our
patients and trying to do the right
thing and second medical legally
so let's change the stakes from a heart
attack to joint pain so a patient does
some research on their own about what
tests might be ordered if one has
chronic pain of multiple joints and
let's say amongst other tests they come
down across an anti-nuclear antibody or
an ana test
the result is neither positive nor
negative like many of our currently over
you know available over-the-counter
tests such as a covid19 test or a
pregnancy test the a a is a titer a
ratio and in addition it comes with
various patterns and a positive test
uh you know a present titer doesn't
necessarily mean autoimmune disease is
present
so how do we reasonably expect patients
to act upon those results where the
action upon the result is going to
hopefully achieve the goal which is
health
this issue of provider responsibility
begs the question
why give tools of medical diagnosis to
patients who cannot administer the
treatment to themselves especially if
providers are absolved from dealing with
the results
you would let a patient either a
discover a problem or b discover
questions based on results
and then legally isolate them from the
provider of any stripe who might be
available to attend to it that they
would not be
mandated to attend to it
um of course they're going to present to
us i think we know as family physicians
as primary care providers as medical
providers of venue stripe
of course they're going to come with
questions and
we would not be able to ignore we and
and that's because we're trying to help
patients in need they're coming with a
question if they get these results
the last point we would make there is
regarding patient billing so in parts
five and six
uh indicating that it does not compel
insurance to cover lab testing not
currently covered and that the lab shall
not submit reimbursement claims to a
payer many payers currently cover
certain laboratory studies for patients
on an annual basis if submitted through
claims properly
this would potentially create a system
where patients may end up paying full
cash price for labs that their insurance
would otherwise cover if submitted from
a medical provider thus creating an
opportunity again for increased costs
i think there's good intention and heart
here as we've heard all throughout so
far i've been in attendance sort of
since the beginning this morning the
goal and spirit of giving patients
agency in their health care is is a very
very good one but i think we have to
consider what this specific wording in
this bill mandates and codifies it
doesn't give guidance as to which labs
to which the law applies it indicates
any lab
and we've heard testimony about some
labs being more appropriate for dat
than others
as i indicated before more labs do not
equal more health and if it did i
promise you we would try it out and we
would have the best health outcomes
because it's kind of what we already do
here in the us
ultimately
we don't feel that hb 381 empowers or
enables patients so much as in many
instances might strand them first
leaving them a c and a drifting is he
trying to interpret results without
context or experience but based off of
uh you know personal research alone
and then even if the example was crystal
clear the diagnosis was crystal clear
leaves them without a provider to attend
and treat they would have to make that
request and by this bill would be
allowed to refuse because they didn't
order the test
and so we felt that all of this if
you're well enough well off enough to
afford the cash price to begin with
um so it we we don't feel that it
balances the risk to patient safety and
the notion of fiscal responsibility with
the concept of the benefit of the agency
which it seeks to to provide so we as
the new hampshire academy of family
physicians um you know urge opposition
to hb 381 as written and we would be
happy to answer any questions at this
time and in the future should it arise
in your deliberations
does anybody on the committee have a
seeing none and exhausting the lists of
house bill 381
we will have
uh half an hour
recess lunch break and
we'll pick up at one o'clock
on house bill 503 establishing the new
hampshire commission on homelessness
and so particularly for representative
long
um
is
i'd like to know have you got this
notice because if not we'll call you
then we're going to pick we're going to
yeah that's fine mr chairman just wanted
to make sure you and anybody else you
especially wanted to have testify would
know we're going to start at one
very good thank you
here
okay i i guess they just haven't turned
the sound on in the committee room yet
thanks jim
good to see you but by the way jim do
you pronounce your name mckay or makai
makai is the scottish way and see right
just halfway between i think
right
but that
that's there's a kinship there because
of in the 1600s the campbell stole the
land of
the makai's and the
and whatever his plan is you know
[Music]
i gather the campbell's had a great deal
to answer for
yeah
yeah it was it was in the highlands in
scotland
are you home or are you in concord
i'm in concord where i came because i
thought that my internet might be more
stable which is called being wrong
because i am told that um
friends in walpole said that walpole was
just fine and of course i've been
i've lost power three times here just
long enough to cause all systems to
i thought i was doing myself a favor
which turns out to have been wrong
madam chair
i have a direct feed
from eversource about
electrical power in our area
and they had 9 700 households out early
this morning
we don't currently have the room turned
is that better
yes thank you so much we can hear you
now come here very good the time being
one o'clock i will call this uh
order and uh we will open the public
hearing on house bill 503
and i will call on representative law to
done
thank you chairman pearson and uh
honourable members of the committee
i'm representative pat long
in hillsborough district 10 within the
city of manchester
madam clark i forwarded my written
testimony to your legislative email
house bill 503 is an attempt to get the
pulse on homelessness in the state of
new hampshire
as i go through my testimony i break
down homelessness into two categories
homelessness in my opinion
is those living in this state with
nowhere to call home
they share housing units with other
families live temporarily with family
members or they may couchsurf or
live live in their vehicles
the other category is unsheltered at our
own house
these are people living on public
property normally uh intense and also
private property
in 2006 legislators established a
commission on homelessness
and speaking with several members of
that commission in 2008 during a
downturn of the economy the commission
stopped meeting
today i believe each municipality
dealing with homelessness are in their
own silos attempting to find solution
often these solutions are in addressing
immediate needs as in un-housed winter
shelters several municipalities have
leased spaces temporarily for people to
have a warm spot when the cold weather
becomes too dangerous in remaining
outside
in march of 2020 when new hampshire
started dealing with cover 19
unsheltered population in several cities
increased substantially people were
afraid to take people into their homes
and the unsheltered were resistant to
going into shelters
i can speak for the city of manchester
in april of 2020 data showed that
manchester had roughly 200 unsheltered
uh residents in july of 2020 the data
showed roughly 250 and in october of
2020 data showed 300 plus
unsheltered people and encampments
around the city of manchester
outreach personnel in manchester
identified 35 plus encampments
including a new encampment settled in
hillsborough superior court north in
manchester
currently there are several funding
mechanisms that the state of new
hampshire receives as in federal dollars
passed through the state along with
state appropriations
in a letter dated from governor sununu
on november 18th to mayors of new
hampshire in response to their letter
regarding challenges in homelessness
the new hampshire department of health
and human services and federal
appropriations in four years equaled
forty million three hundred and twenty
one thousand nine hundred and twenty six
dollars
i believe that passage of house bill 503
will immediately allow this commission
to ensure public dollars are being
expended at its highest level in best
practice solution recommendations
in december the new hampshire coalition
to end homelessness released its annual
report on the state of homelessness
as reported in the new hampshire
business review titled
state senate study sounds alarm on
homeless tidal wave
and it's january 15th to 28th 2021
edition
the good news is there are no studies
that need to be done we have all we need
to begin immediately addressing best
practice solution
this commission through expertise can
affect best practice positive change
immediately
the governor to his credit established
through executive order a council on
housing stability
the meetings that i have attended lean
more towards affordable housing an issue
that absolutely needs this attention
i am of the opinion affordable housing
would not address the unsheltered of the
homeless for that matter again speaking
just within manchester outreach workers
have identified over 80 percent of the
unsheltered have underlying mental
health service needs
and the percentages increase
substantially when you include substance
use disorder these needs are imperative
prior to addressing any services on
independent living
in closing we have implemented the tools
in addressing mental health and
substance use disorder with the 10-year
mental health plan in the doorway
program
what we need now are experts to agree
with the initiatives in stopping this
tidal waves of unsheltered and
homelessness in the state of new
hampshire
mr chairman i received from
representative shapiro an amendment
adding two entities
and i also received the communication
from mr padma with the new hampshire
medical society wanting to add
a representative from them mosul
so i hope you look favorably on house
bill 503 and i thank you for your
consideration
thank you for your testimony um does
question mr chair
yes representative soloway uh thank you
mr chairman thank you representative
long for proposing this bill i think
it's terribly important do you have any
additional information representative
long on homelessness in the rural areas
of new hampshire
well there's the uh
that article in new hampshire business
review does address that it's worse in
those areas
um and frankly they're moving towards
you know if i'm thrown out of my house
because of a drug addiction
um
you know in
in chichester i'm not about to move in
the woods i'm going to go where there's
a group that i can live with whether
dover or wherever so there is some
information on that
thank you
any further questions
i see representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and thank you
representative long um certainly i've
been involved with the homelessness here
in concord and greatly appreciate what
you're doing
uh in terms of efficacy and timeliness
etc
this seems to me move forward as you
said immediately
but sometimes things get uh bogged down
uh my question centers around uh we have
before is house bill 157 which is health
care planning with a rather expansive um
list of that commission
are you familiar with that and if so
would would that be a place that we
could
use as a subcommittee
of that and
instead of having a multitude of further
commissions
thank you for the question
representative i i um
i i firmly believe that homelessness
needs its own particular
um
advocacy group on that
um i certainly understand i'm not
familiar with the bill you mentioned
um but
you know i think it's
it's been a long it's been long since
new hampshire addressed cohesively
uh homelessness
representative gay
thank you mr chairman um
senator senator
representative long
it's the real concern
that
shelters don't address this permanent
housing i mean it's the real problem
that these people
are mentally ill or substance that
suffers from
substance abuse
so just providing housing is not
i mean the hardest that is that doesn't
address the real problem
there's a lot of excuse to deal with
thank you for the question
representative gay i i uh i
wholeheartedly agree in my testimony i
state that they're there there are
unsheltered people that
if we had
20 000 affordable housing units
everywhere in the state couldn't afford
an affordable housing unit
you know i know they're looking at uh 80
medium income which in manchester is
roughly 1500 a month
um i i know several
i know 80 of the people in the
manchester unsheltered uh encampments
would not be able to afford those so
you know we first need to address
representative merchants
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
and also for bringing this to our
attention it's a very important
societal issue that we have to face and
particularly here with the pandemics i
want to say thank you for bringing it
forward
and given
the fact that we have a lot of data
already in place
dealing with this issue
would it be better for us to have an ad
hoc committee to create legislation in
the fall
to address the issue versus the
commission that will take another year
which then would drag it out another
year after that
process issue as a question at that
point in time if we already have a lot
of data could we not speed this up by
having an ad hoc committee and introduce
legislation in the fall
thank you for the question uh
representative merchant i i um
i don't believe we need added
legislation i
the money the 40 million dollars is out
there currently
and i think these experts on this
commission
could um you know within their own
entities form a new hampshire plan and
have it implemented without legislative
you know permission
thank you mr chairman
thank you pat for
bringing in this very important
legislation
do you agree that
people with
severe mental illness addictions and
other
conditions like that
make up a good part of the
homeless
population and therefore the importance
of
coordination between
the 10-year mental health plan for
example and housing
is a central issue
in this
condition
yeah thank you representative mckay i i
certainly i certainly believe that those
with mental health um
cannot on their own
be responsible to manage getting into
getting into somewhere so i believe they
need their they need their hands held
um uh just you know they need services
mental health services and substance use
also
uh and
they need their hands held into helping
them
live independently
um so you're absolutely right to to
offer any benefits
to any person that's unhoused with a
mental health issue
you know i'm of the opinion that they
can't grasp that on their own it's
they're dependent on us to
hold their hand and walk them through
that
representative gay
thank you mr chairman
um
do you think
it's possible
to do a combination of what was
suggested start with an ad hoc and start
now
and then
when when a commission could be
go into what you know start working
transition so the addressing could
happen now or do you think the funding
won't happen
unless
the
that
or do you think that an ad hoc
committee could not get the funding to
be
starting to address the problem right
now
and then the other concern i have
are there
other patterns that we could follow
because my understanding is that a lot
of people who are in this category
mentally
are emotionally
ill
are scared to death they won't even go
into a shelter they're so fearful
so are there some patterns we can follow
thank you for the question
representative i mean as far as an ad
hoc committee
you know once again there's there's uh
you know
i mean i have 19 members
uh and there's a possibility of a 22
member but these are all experts in
specific care whether it's mental health
substance use
uh unhoused shelters
um training in job security
um you know training and budgeting these
these are all the experts that already
have all the data
with which to implement um a cohesive
um state plan um so
with respect to the first part of the
question i
you know i i think this commission is a
good commission to be able to deliver in
that they're they're already trying in
their silos to get that done now
uh and there is money coming and there's
every year there's money coming to
homelessness um
i mean it appears there's 10 million a
year coming from
dhhs and uh the federal appropriations
uh and with respect to shelters you're
absolutely right that
you know the people that i've spoken to
on houzz
that
i'm not a psychiatrist but
i i know there's something
not
right
do not want to go with the shelter
they don't even want to talk to me
you know however our outreach people
have been successful in
getting a relationship with them and
thank you
representative nelson
thank you i'm sorry i've introduced got
into this lady
would a police somebody representing the
police department be a good member of a
commission
or whatever you set up
not somebody against the homeless
obviously but somebody that's out on the
street working
with the homeless and dealing with the
issues from their perspective
uh thank you representative for the
question i i um
i mean the only experience i know
within police departments is the
enforcement of
unhoused sleeping on sidewalks and in
private
private hallways
in in their cars
um i
i mean i'm not i'm not sure uh with
respect to a
cohesive plan
uh put forth for the state of new
hampshire i'm not sure i mean i i could
be wrong but i'm not sure that they fit
into this category
any other questions for representative
law
seeing none thank you representative for
your bill
testimony
the chair would next like to call
patrick ho
from the new hampshire psychiatric
society
hello can you all hear me
yes
thank you and thank you mr chairman and
representatives of the community or the
committee sorry my name is patrick ho i
am the president of the new hampshire
psychiatric society my testimony today
is on behalf of both the new hampshire
psychiatric society as well as the new
hampshire medical society where i also
serve as an executive council member
um i'll keep my testimony short today
and also stick around for question uh
questions but i think as we see the
numbers of children and adults around
the state waiting in emergency
departments for admission to an
inpatient psychiatric unit this is a
stark reminder that we lack the
resources to care for not only the
mental health needs of our citizens but
also the health-related social needs of
our citizens
it is not infrequent that homeless
people who feel that they have no other
options but to come to their nearest
emergency department
where oftentimes they will be evaluated
by psychiatry find themselves in the
long queue awaiting a psychiatric
inpatient bed
i think that a commission to study
homelessness in our state would be
potentially a very valuable intervention
that could make recommendations on how
we might provide more resources for
those who are homeless other than
already sparse emergency department beds
and psychiatric inpatient beds the new
hampshire psychiatric society and the
new hampshire medical society do support
this bill and as uh representative long
had mentioned before we we also believe
that and would request that a
psychiatrist be included on this
commission due to the high co-occurrence
of homeless homelessness and mental
health disorders
i thank you for your time and and am
available for any questions
gay thank you mr chairman
um dr dr is there um is there a i keep
using the word pattern but i mean an
example
of
you know is
is this
basically
the issue that we just don't provide
enough psychiatric
care
and hospitals for all the people
who need it
thank you for your question
representative gay um i i think that
what we see here is is certainly a
bi-directional phenomenon and a
bi-directional issue and what i mean by
that is that certainly not everybody who
is homeless has a mental health disorder
um and and certainly not everybody that
has a mental health disorder is homeless
and i think what we see is that those
who are homeless oftentimes as a result
of
many social needs that that lead to
homelessness do develop mental health
disorders and or substance use disorders
and oftentimes because of the the rigors
of mental health disorders then many
people who have mental health disorders
do become homeless as well so i think
that um
instead of focusing on um on hospital
capacity which is something we've done
in the past and something that's proven
to be
really costly and ineffective i think
instead trying to prevent the occurrence
of mental health disorders by providing
resources for those who need it
would be certainly money well spent and
also inefficient use of such a
commission
thank you
see no further questions thank you sir
and the last one on my list who signed
up to testify we heard from her this
morning
bringing back sophia
leon de lilo from me
from the new hampshire high school
democrats she's a high school student in
manchester
hi can you hear me welcome back
perfect all right um thank you everybody
for taking my testimony again for the
record again my name is sophia
biandalilo i'm 14. i live in manchester
and i'm speaking today on behalf of the
new hampshire high school democrats in
support of hb503
um i know that we're pretty behind
schedule so i will keep this short um
but i'm sure that many of you are aware
of what happened just before
thanksgiving last year in 2020
if you're not though there was a
situation where
maybe half a dozen or a dozen homeless
people were temporarily housed outside
of the hillsborough county courthouse in
manchester and state police arrived in
late november to practically try to
evict them
according to witnesses who were there at
the time and a few videos that were
taken the state police actually ripped
the tents people had made there they
threw away personal belongings and they
caused a lot of turmoil there and all
this was just a few days after the
notice was posted that they were going
to arrive so there was very little time
for these people to relocate before
again their possessions were thrown away
and their homes were destroyed
um i think this commission would help us
find out more about why people are being
forced to stay outside and find a better
solution so that we can prevent things
like this from happening again that
would not only be a huge improvement for
our houseless neighbors but it would
also allow us to improve our communities
and help people feel more in touch with
their neighborhoods and where they live
i can also say definitely that this is
an issue that affects youth particularly
because not only are there a lot of
children and adolescents that are forced
into unfortunate living situations
because
their parents aren't able to support a
family or whatever other reasons that
are outside of their control um but also
because there are a lot of runaway teens
who have to escape their family
situations and that causes them to live
outside of the home so as a home as a
high schooler
i can definitely say that this bill
would help us find a way to help a lot
of people find stability and be able to
get back into better situations so
overall i think it's a really great bill
that's very nonpartisan and i asked the
committee to recommend octopass on hp503
i don't see any questions but thank you
with that i see no one else on my list
or
nothing
so
chairman pearson there are two people
who do have their hands up if you'd like
to recognize them
oh okay i have information to the
contrary but uh let me call in on molly
lynch
good afternoon everyone my name is molly
lynch i'm an attorney with the
department of health and human services
and i am also a legislative liaison with
the department
the department uh respectfully opposes
um hb 503 um you know we recognize um we
i heard the testimony from the prior
speakers and you know we share their
concerns however we feel that it is
duplicative of the comprehensive work
that is being done by the council on
housing stability enacted in november
2020 by executive order the department
feels creating an additional commission
is not necessary it will strain dhhs
staff resources and also have the
potential to create dual plans for
homelessness which will not help solve
the problem
the council on housing stability
includes a comprehensive comprehensive
vision and membership that focuses on
housing stability for all new hampshire
citizens including addressing the
homelessness issue
the council has submitted an initial
plan to governor sununu and is currently
in the process of working on june 1st
2021 deliverables which include but are
not limited to a plan um on homelessness
the council has um
he has support including the support of
consultants which includes the
corporation for supportive housing to
assist in the work
so um with that you know i'm happy to
answer any questions and if i don't know
the answer i'm happy to take it back to
the department and specifically the
division on economic and housing
stability
representative gay thank you mr chairman
uh could you repeat slowly enough that i
can write it down
you say this would be the duplicative
work of which department our new agency
our new commission i'm not i couldn't
quite catch
sure um we feel it's repetitive of the
council on housing stability that was in
that was enacted by executive order in
november of 2020 by governor sununu
and that
council has a website um which i'm i'm
happy i don't know if there's no chat
function but i'm happy to um share um
with the committee as well and they have
deliverables that will be that they're
in the process of working on
that the deliverables will be due june
follow up
yes who
how many people are on it what who do
they represent
sure i actually um was looking at the
website and i have it up there it has
many members
um the new hampshire housing finance
authority
the new hampshire coalition against
domestic and sexual violence housing
action new hampshire
dhhs is a member department of
corrections
bureau bureau of housing supports
division of behavioral health services
with the department the municipal
association new hampshire catholic
charities the laconia police department
department of education department of
safety department of transportation
department of business and economic
affairs department of employment
security i can keep going there's
there's several members that city of
concord city of keene city of rochester
the new hampshire coalition to end
homelessness um a parent who has current
and or recent lived experience of
housing instability and actually a young
adult
who also has experienced housing and
stability um there's a few other um
there's a
few other individuals as well
in organizations
one more one more
okay who is on it who actually works
with homeless people
well as a the bureau of housing supports
i also you know also the
with the department um i believe mental
health with the department
there was also the new hampshire
coalition to end homelessness is also on
this council
i i know catholic charities i mentioned
catholic charities they do a lot i
believe with the homeless homelessness
as well
the chair has a question did you do a
side by side
with on one's hand
page two of house bill 503
that lists its duties from
line six
to 18
and on the other hand looking at the
duties of the
housing stability council
did you do a side by side to see how
they match up
okay representative merchants
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
miss lynch for taking my question
with all the work that's been done
by the council i want to say thank you
for getting the work done
one of the things also in house bill 503
on the second page
is a question about recommendation with
legislation
so
given all the work that's been done what
recommendations for legislation has come
the council i believe has deliverables
due in
june
i don't believe they have um i can
definitely take that back to see if
there's any legislative proposals being
worked on and i apologize i have i'm
looking at the bill on my screen so i
don't have the lined version
mr chairman to follow up for me
is there going to be an interim report
coming out before the final one that we
can look at
to see how it lines up with the bill
therefore we could look at potential
legislation or possibly even modifying
the bill so we can sort of
i do not know there isn't going to be an
interim but i can definitely take take
that question back
representative
thank you very much um given that the
council on housing stability you said
was created by executive order in
november 2020.
i am curious whether it is dealing
primarily with housing stability
questions related to covid
or long term because this has certainly
been a problem for many years
not just with regard to covet and so i'm
looking at the charge because the charge
of this is a broad charge
that is
beyond the scope of covid so was the
scope of that more to deal with the
the council definitely is looking at
covet that is um you know that is
definitely something that they are
follow up
but i mean are they also though looking
at the big picture that existed
pre-coveted and not
focusing more on covid because this bill
is the big picture i believe it's the
meeting it's looking at all issues um in
addition to covet um i'm looking at
their initial report and action plan
that's dated december 14th 2020 and it
you know there's an introduction
it looks at homelessness and housing and
security in new hampshire on page one
and then i think on page
seven of 13
romans 7 it looks at the impact of the
coven 19 pandemic so i would say that
it's looking at a variety of things not
with the information of the committee i
just received a text from house
committee services saying that they will
provide for us the side by side between
the tasks that this bill would establish
and the tasks in the council we've just
been speaking of so we'll know that
answer pretty soon
the chair recognizes
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you
miss lynch for taking my question
um
it seems to me that when you listed some
of the representatives on the council
that perhaps and
i might be wrong but perhaps that they
they represented
um they tended to represent more state
agencies
and
bureaucratic agencies dealing with um
housing instability whereas this
commission that's being proposed seems
to be more represented by organizations
that are out on the street working with
homeless people that might be an
oversimplification
but for example
um you talked about the bureau of um
behavioral health
whereas this
um new proposed commission would have
representatives of the mental health
centers
who i know at least in my area have a
um
somebody who works specifically with
homelessness in the monadnock area
so my question is if these um this
council and this commission really are
duplicative which sounds like it might
be the case
would there be the possibility of the
council absorbing some of the
organizations or representatives from
some of the organizations from this
proposed commission
on to the council that's already
functioning
i think that's a great question um i i
can definitely take that back i mean i i
might um
respectfully disagree um that you know
the council it does seem to focus very
heavily on state agencies but i would
say that it does have you know
community members new hampshire catholic
charities various police departments so
i wouldn't say that it's you know it is
a little bit more state more state
agency there are a lot of state agencies
represented but i think that's a great
point to further investigate about
whether members could be added to the
current council
follow-up
i do want to apologize if i was
oversimplifying but um perhaps this um
if there is any truth to what what i um
seem what i thought
maybe this would enrich the efforts of
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman and thank you ms
lynch for taking my question but given
that you feel that this uh commission
that's proposed would be duplicative of
the one established by executive order
number 22.
and given that we all anticipate that
the state of emergency will at some
point be lifted
do you not think it might be true for
this committee to invent this bill to
continue the council for housing
stability and statute and perhaps add
some members as has been suggested by
representatives
um you know i i would of course you know
for an official position with the
department i'd have to take it back but
to me that makes great sense thank you
anyone else
okay i'm sorry thank you mr chairman i
think i'm being heard now
is that right yes thank you
i just had a couple of questions perhaps
it could be partly answered by
representative shapiro
uh but i the question there's three
additional members who added to the list
that was on here and although they
mentioned that there were three more to
make it 21 i don't know who those other
three are so if somebody could say that
and the second question i had which i
hope could be answered is is
representative long still on and if he
is
what's his impression about how the
mixture of these two efforts would work
representative long's invited to speak
if he's still with us there he is hey
i am thank you mr chairman thank you
representative snow for the question um
i
i still firmly believe that the
commission established in 503 are on the
grounds people that have the expertise
and what needs to be done and i think
the best interest of the state
uh
to
to affect this
addressing of homelessness would be
through a commission and not housing
stability
thank you
and
are you aware of the three new people
that were added to it that aren't listed
in the bill
or someone
can i answer that uh mr chairman
[Music]
go ahead
well representative snow the the added
three are the new hampshire providers
association new hampshire community
behavioral health association
thank you that's what i thought they
were but anyway thank you very much i
appreciate your input and all the work
you've put in on this
thank you representative wong
[Music]
folsom
yes thank you thank you mr chairman
um
miss lynch i was wondering um
does the
sorry i have to
go back to where i wrote that note down
does the council on housing stability
i believe some members are from the
they're i believe some of the members of
the of the house and senate are are part
of the council
um and just to clarify there there was
an interim report that the council did
and um the governor does have authority
to add new members and the council does
um
just follow up
okay um
representative
long if i can ask him a question that
it has been uh put forward possibly
uh by uh representative marsh that
this
we could move this
council and this commission
kind of take our time and smoosh it all
together and come up with the best of
the best
um and are you open to that with your
bill
thank you representative for the
question and uh
i i am open with that if the um if the
council on housing stability had an arm
of
strictly dedicated to homelessness
i
thank you mr chairman and thank you ms
lynch just to clarify
am i correct and i'm very sorry if this
is duplicative and if it is just tell me
so and i'll find out from somebody else
but i had to step away from a minute
am i correct in thinking that this bill
was created under an emergency order and
if so
it the council created by emergency
order
will vanish when the state
of the emergency is over and the order
terminates is that correct
i understand that the the governor could
then
issue an executive order
um
having any other council he wants but
but this specific one
would not necessarily continue is that
correct
um there is my understanding is that
there's no ending and i'm looking at the
um
executive order that created the council
which is 20 20 22
well 2020-22
and i don't believe it was created
pursuant to the emergency order um
okay thank you for the clarification
any other questions
and i believe there's one more person in
the cue to testify henry volume
uh henry below you are called to the
meeting
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
for the record my name is henry value
and i'm here this afternoon on behalf of
the new hampshire community action
association
some of you may be
familiar with the community action
agencies there are
five of them located around the state
it was established
the agencies were established back in
um
and those agencies work
uh to get people out of poverty um and
to become protected productive members
you know of the community um
so we would be happy to participate on
the committee uh also
um if you were to add the group again
it's called the new hampshire community
action association
and uh with that i'd be happy to answer
i see none
and that's not oh
what's that
you may ask a question thank you mr
chair
thank you um
i'm sorry i'm not gonna say your last
name right um
so i'm just gonna say dear henry uh
with uh your organization um do you work
with the northern half of the state as
well as the southern half
yeah so the five uh action the community
action agencies uh there's the
tri-county cap that's the one up in the
north country basically it's coast
county
there's a stratford county cap
is southern new hampshire services which
is basically nashua and manchester
there is southwestern uh which is over
by the keene area and then there's a
belmont merrimack county cap and they
provide you know homeless
services housing services employment and
training services uh to help people
get employed they do the um
they do the fuel assistance program
a lot of
they qualify basically people for a lot
of the federal dollars that come to the
state for assistance um
and uh so they they work with this
population uh you know because sometimes
the population goes
up through the system and back through
the system uh they try to keep them
going up through the system and
um you know get them employment and
being
uh productive members of the community
so they they do work sort of hands-on
with a lot of these folks
um
and i think you know would be a valuable
one
um would you please pronounce your last
name for me again so i can write it out
phonetically that's yes it's uh sorry
it's it's a little french uh it's
pronounced veyu
and i've spelled v
e i l l e u x thank you
okay thank you very much
but it's henry not only
that's correct
well thank you monsieur for your
testimony thank you
and i i don't see any more hands up and
what i'm proposing to do is to wait a
week to accept this because perhaps
and
from what i've been gleaning from the
testimony perhaps there might be a
conversation
um
with the
council or with the governor
on the idea of
somehow emerging groups
or we can also wait because we want to
see that side-by-side
parallel of duties and
memberships and you know somebody might
want that member that amendment to bring
in
uh another group or two to the bill so
i'm gonna wait for a week
and if there's an amendment or several
coming uh please work on them right away
so we can look at them on friday i'm
still hoping to exec
next
monday
i call on whoa look at that
thank you mr chairman will that side by
side also include membership as well as
the tasks of the different groups
well i believe there's somebody from the
fourth floor who's monitoring our
meeting and running it and i
we can ask them you just asked if that
could be the case as well
so not just the duties but also
absolutely
now
we are finished simplicity
excuse me for simplicity could that list
of people also include the four new
groups that were going to be added to
that list under uh representative long's
bill
now i'm going to open a an executive
session
on house we'll start with house bill 572
and i believe that we have an amendment
that's going to be presented a
representative merchant you're listed
first and would you
speak to your amendments and why it
addresses some questions that came up
when we had our hearing the other day
thank you mr chairman
if it's okay with you i'd like to turn
this over to representative cushman i've
been working with
and i want to say thank you for her work
um to introduce the amendment
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
merchant
uh it was a pleasure working with you on
this um
so we
we changed some language from the
original bill
where it said cdc
uh recommended vaccines in the
first paragraph of the bill
to
list
the current
adult
schedules
recommended vaccines
um specifically each one
um in doing so if any more are added to
the cdc
recommended schedule
they will have to have legislative
approval first
we also clarified the language
there was some confusion over
whether pharmacists
could administer vaccines to individuals
of 18 years or older and we clarified
that uh or under and we clarified that
to
say yes it's it's only two adults 18
years of age or older online
we also added
that the vaccines must be approved by
the
food and drug administration
the amendment that's here that you may
have says federal and drug
administration that was a
typo
but we have emailed you all a copy of
the latest version
of the amendment where that is
fixed and says food and drug
administration
the
paragraph three has
just been changed to clarify that
um
every vaccine that's administered the
pharmacist pharmacy intern or licensed
computer training specific to
administration of their respective
vaccines
instead of just the specific ones that
and then
you'll see roman numeral d
says
uh provide notice to the primary care
provider when when one is designated by
the patient of the administration of any
vaccine
the physicians are aware of
what their
patients have
received as
medical interventions outside of their
office
and then we just clarified the language
in
numeral
six
to say report the vaccination in the
state vaccine registry
with patient consent
or when required by state federal law
this allows some flexibility uh pending
and lastly
section the last section that was added
vii
7 says
submit reports of any adverse reactions
following vaccination to the cdc vaccine
adverse event reporting system
within three days of being made aware of
such adverse effects occurring
this is already required by federal law
but this just clarifies and puts it in
statute for pharmacists pharmacy
uh advanced
licensed advanced pharmacy technicians
and pharmacy interns to be aware of it
that's all and i think that we have a
the chair would like to know is
legislative services going to
give us
another typed out amendment
with another amendment number
uh yes mr chairman ols has already done
that it's on the screen right now and
the amendment which i believe
representative cushman intended to move
and that is the same as 467h with the
exception of that word change in line
10.
there's a single word on line 10 where
word federal has been replaced with the
word food because there was a
would you like to
remove the amendment i i would like to
move that amendment can you tell me the
number again zero five seven six h and
representative marshall ii
okay cushman moves
march seconds
representative wood
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
representative uh excuse me christian
for taking my questions uh i
i must have been on my
probably my end here but it broke up
just a little bit
uh relative to sections five
and section six
and if you could just uh clarify
i see that the notice goes to the
primary care provider
buried in this is that if they don't
have a primary care
do they get a card
uh i think that representative merchant
may be able to answer that better i
believe it's already required by law
that
uh you have to give a record of the
immunization to
someone who receives one but i thought
that was the case but i didn't see it so
i thought maybe i didn't want to make a
false assumption
thank you representative woodson thank
you represent cushman um when a patient
gets a vaccine regardless of where they
get the vaccine they're required to be
given
to them as a
by the cdc is a vaccine
report about the vaccine itself side
effects and so forth etc so that's given
and if i may um the language we have
here
currently in statute
follow mr chair follow up
um yeah thank you um in the next section
on section six
uh could you clarify exactly how that
would work recording the vaccination
state uh vaccine registry uh broke up
there and i wasn't
so if you could run that for me again
please
um
yes grab some coachman you like me to
address that or do you want to address
it you can you can take it if you like
thank you
so basically we have another bill before
the legislative body and that's house
bill 2-2-1
which is an opt-in or opt-out so the way
i
way representative cushman and i wrote
this
was that if it's an opt-out
then
the pharmacist has to comply with the
opt out if it's an opt in barnes has to
comply with the opt-in
so instead of holding up this bill
based upon that bill we wrote in such a
way that regardless of which way it goes
the pharmacist will be compliant
in either direction
okay i thank you i just uh right at that
crucial point uh the explanation broke
up and so
thank you
anyone else
doesn't have to be a question could be a
representative
yes thank you um
well i appreciate the idea of having the
list
of vaccinations extracted from the cdc
i
i really wonder why do that rather than
just default to the cdc because
we often do that we often will have a
reference to
federal regulations because those can
change
and the difficulty is if we if a
if
something is dropped or if something is
added we have a very cumbersome and slow
process that may take as long as a year
to a year and a half before it can be
modified in statute whereas if it's
changed in the cdc list
it's automatically there and that can go
into effect immediately which is why on
the other vaccine bill i just defaulted
to the cdc list rather than list them
all because it will be a fluid thing it
doesn't change often but it will be
fluid
any reservations about moving back to
that i see representative marsh has a
hand up maybe he's got a good answer for
that well let's ask representative marsh
yes thank you for that question uh
representative
uh i will just say that sometimes this
is the way this message is made and this
is the way the parties came from
agreement and i would love to keep them
in agreement so uh that's the answer to
yeah i understand sasha it can be made
different ways but i just understand i
want to understand the rationale for not
defaulting
to it rather than
doing an enumeration
if i may miss the chairman
um
representative knick i hear you it was a
compromise between myself and
representative cushman um she felt
uncomfortable allowing for it to be
automatic and in respect to her concerns
i agree to at that point time to list
the current vaccines
in order to move it forward and have her
support
understood
anybody else
with a yellow or
other color hand up
no hands on
then
we can call the roll on amendment zero
five seven six h moved by
representative cushman seconded by
representative marsh would the clerk
there we go sorry about that oh
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon i'll come back
representative nelson
yes
representative acton
representative gay
yes representative cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representatives melvin
yes
representative king
representative cofoult
yes
representative weber
yes and representative snow just called
me to say he had to step out to get his
shot and we'll be back so he is not
present at the moment okay
um
representative mckay
yes
representative knurk
representative soloway yes
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham
yes
representative woods
representative merchant
yes
representative pearson yes
and it appears that representative
mcmahon's still not available
so i'll just put him as absent
so that is 19 yeses and two absent
now the bill
as amended
you have a motion representative
merchant
yes i do
um i make a motion to
at the past with amendment on house bill
572.
do we have a second second march seconds
representative christman
thank you mr chairman
i support this bill as amended um in my
discussions with representative merchant
there were a couple of other issues that
i just want to state for the record that
with every vaccine that's given except
the coca-19 vaccines
there is required
to also be given to each patient the
vaccine information sheet
and
because they're not
require i i propose that we add the
manufacturer fact sheet for recipients
and caregivers
to be given with the covid19 vaccines
however because
they're currently not required of
other medical providers um
it was decided that it would not be um
it would be fair to have
separate you know double standard for
physicians and you know would be kind of
confusing for patients
for some would get the fact sheet some
wouldn't
so i'd like to work on that next
session
next house session to
to
amend the law to make it so those are
required and also i
instead of approved by the food and drug
administration
just because the only vaccine on here
that is
not licensed is the copa 19 vaccine
and
if by some chance it starts to become
common practice for emergency youth
authorities use authorization to be
um
implemented
that uh
rather we have licensed and then if
there's a true emergency
where a vaccine needs to be dispensed
quickly um likely there will be an
emergency order to that effect
and then the only other thing that i
would would have liked to see
but again i support the bill as amended
now
is i would have liked to see
after food and drug administration and
as recommended by the cdc
adult vaccination schedule
the reason for that being that
as a
as a way to
ensure that new hampshire consumers are
um protected from
kind of just
gross sales practices
we keep in mind that not every
um
vaccine is recommended for every
adult there are contraindications and i
think that pharmacists will make that
decision anyway but i just wanted to
mention that those i wanted to have in
there but we'll work on those another
time and i support the bill as written
today
i see sausage construction in your
future
yes representative go ahead
yes i just want to on the record say
that i did speak with
representative cushman on this and i'd
be willing to work with her on the bill
my concern was that we have a uniform
standard regardless of the provider um
so
be willing to sit down with her roll up
my sleeves and figure out how we can
make something that works across all
providers and not just roll out a tip of
a provider which this bill would have
done
thank you
representative webber you have your hand
done
thank you mr chairman i don't know if
i'm under a continuing obligation to
disclose this but i just wanted to state
that my housemate has returned home and
is in another part of the house but
maybe wandering through so i thought i
would just put that on the record thank
you
thank you um actually in the last
conversation you just maybe have to
circle back to that issue about the cdc
list
and i did not catch this the first time
through because we list the set of
vaccines that can be given
um and which have been approved but when
one looks at the cdc guidance
and i think this might have been
commented on but i didn't quite catch it
clearly
it is not that these are given at any
point in time they are recommended by
the cdc
for specific age groups
in other words like hpv is for a
specific age group um
zoster is recommended for specific age
groups
we do not have anything in this that
restricts it to the age groups for which
it is recommended which would mean that
a pharmacist could follow this and give
these vaccinations to anybody even if it
is not recommended by the cdc for that
specific age group and i'm wondering if
we could still have the laundry list in
so that we it so that we
respect what representative cushman
wanted
but still add in a phrase it would say
as recommended by the cdc
so that we capture
that age feature
uh the demographic feature that is
important in their recommendation
because
they're different for different ages
if i can address it mr chairman yes
please mr representative connor i hear
the concern but i think as a
professional
um i do trust that they're going to
follow the cdc guidelines without being
instructed the statute to do that
i don't think anyone else has that same
statutory requirement
physicians don't have it pas don't have
it nurse practitioners don't have it
natural paths don't have it so again
back to my comment is whatever we do for
one provider we should be ensure that
all other providers live play by the
same rules
i can appreciate that thank you
uh just a point of information mr
chairman please our speakers are
referring to cdc guidelines i suspect
they mean fda guidelines
is that correct
no
oh the they are there are cdc guidelines
that have been developed
by the their immunization schedules by
their immunization
committees um i've got it pulled up
finally
recommended adult immunization schedule
for adults
for ages 19 and older and this comes
from the cdc not the fda because the fda
looks at the question of is it safe and
is it effective the cdc is looking at
the um
at the public health issues as to when
is the right time and for whom is it the
so for example even influenza different
recommendations for older than younger
but i think representative merchant has
made a very good point and that is that
we don't put that same restriction on a
medical provider
they're supposed to know it
i guess it's because we're moving into
newer uncharted territory
and my question will be do we think that
the
pharmacists will
be
referring to the cdc guidelines and make
sure
that they are following those cdc
guidance as should the medical provider
fight
canard gets a good point
but also today a pharmacist can give a
shingles vaccine
there's nothing in there says they have
to follow in statute cdc but we do
expect that they understand the age
requirements for a single vaccine that
somebody coming in who's 18 years old
doesn't get a shingles vaccine
so
i want to say thank you for bringing up
the point but i think the point has been
addressed professionally by the
pharmacists themselves
got it
representative
yes thank you
i
should sorry um
i uh
i i agree with the premise of your
question uh representative conner
and i think it'll be something good to
work on bipartisanly next year
are you looking good and the question
is on
house bill
572 as amended
and the motion is
amendment yeah
how to read it
number zero five seven six eight zero
five seven six h thank you and uh
representative merchant moved it
representative moore seconded it the
thank you mr chair representative marsh
yes representative mcmahon
i believe he's still away um
representative nelson yes
representative acton
yes
representative gay
yes representative cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representative melvin yes
representative king
yes representative cofolt
yes
representative weber
yes representative mckay
i think he's still gone okay
representative knurk
yes
representative soloway yes
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods yes
and representative merchant
absolutely
representative pearson
yes
okay 19
uh in the affirmative and two absent
and representative merchant would you
write the committee report and without
mr chairman when did the committee
all right thank you
yeah
but don't get used to that when we're
all back happy in the same room you
don't leave
oh yeah but it's not we don't have a
voting session
do we they still send the calendar
that's the deadline for the calendars
if i may unless there is a house session
next week they will not print committee
reports in the calendar right oh okay
they still want the calendar still out
there on their deadline i'm now going to
open the exec session on house bill 220
and this is the incredible shrinking
bill
lots of good work has gone into this and
representative marsh who had an
amendment yes i would like to move
just just by point of record
the original bill was already amended
by
334 h
so this bill
replaces
everything except
well
mr chairman i was waiting for a second
of my motion before i started talking i
think you're wise to do that who will
second cushman
okay now
yes to speak to my motion amendment
is identical to the amendment that we
already adopted in the addition of a
single sentence at the very end
and the sentence was added this morning
because the department of corrections
brought a concern to us last night that
they
were concerned that their inmates who
they were asking to participate in food
service in
the state prison
they were currently trying to have them
vaccinated for hepatitis a and total
hepatitis a operate in the state prison
i believe that clearly meets the direct
threat uh
criteria that's here but they were not
convinced they'd be qualified as
employees so they asked that we had an
additional sentence to make it clear
that they felt under the same
criteria this was already in humanity
adopted by definition
any discussion on
let me say because i have the paperwork
on this um
at the appearing on the original bill
there were
245 people
signing in to
support the bill and it seems like
africa wanted to testify there were 52
people opposing and one person neutral
so that's that's the box score for the
hearing
any other
discussion
representative woods
oh sorry
relative to the numbers sometimes it can
be very confusing because
some of the material that comes out and
you may have already adjusted for this
sometimes the opinions appear
at least in my inbox uh before the
amendments come through
and therefore it's a very different
flavor uh and you may have already
adjusted for that perhaps
no this is why some committees in my
experience
don't tell
how many people signed in one way or the
other
um i was asked to do that and when i
didn't lose the paperwork i try to
remember to do that but yeah you can
also get a block group of people
just flooding
the paperwork here and you may not
necessarily know where they're from
and so then that also skews the data so
i personally put almost no stock and
you know if a thousand people testify
sign in one way and 50 the other way
that could simply mean somebody's better
organized
not necessarily that the thousand
represents the groundswell so thank you
for that
thank you i i also just wanted to make a
quick note about
that
about the sign ins and the other thing
is that it seems to me that we have
received a significant amount of input
subsequent to
the bill
signing in sheet having closed and my
understanding would be that those also
am i correct in thinking that those are
also not
um
included in the final tallies
that is correct the tally is for people
who signed in one way or the other about
unless
committee services
she may be in another committee i
apologize could you repeat the question
yeah the question is when i'm given the
tally that i just announced there were
245 in support and 52 in opposition that
was to the original bill correct
correct i've never i we don't get
updates after
uh we had a long discussion and then
somebody says hey i'm going to bring an
amendment to such and such there's no
tally on what people will
write in
to express their opinions on
them correct
no not typically um some people will add
it into um
they'll add it in creatively but
otherwise there's there's no mechanism
for that
okay yeah sure is there any way is there
any way for the public to see an
amendment i thought there was not
yes
you can see the amendments now yes house
committee services has made them
available they become available
once they've been adopted that's always
been the case but ant house committee
services i believe is
creating a process that they can be made
so to work in progress i know that was
bill
any further discussion on the amendments
575-h
yes um
i'm getting a little confused um trying
to put the amendment next to the
original bill and i wonder if someone
who's more knowledgeable than i could
speak to
um
as the bill
would be amended if we vote on vote to
what would actually be different
than the way things
representative march yes we already
adopted amendment uh
zero three four four h which replaced
section one with the new section one and
left the enact the uh uh
when it becomes effective clause in
effect uh
this
i i could have just added to that
section one but i did the whole thing
again because it was easier vote for ols
and for everybody in the call to see
what we're talking about here
and basically this replaces the section
one in the original build with a new
section one um which as you can see is
follow up
so my question is um practically
speaking
what will be different if we pass this
bill
than is the case without passing this
that's
that's always a good question and i
believe that question is more in order
i guess i'm wondering
what is the purpose of this bill at this
point i think it you know before
when there were more things in it some
of which i disagreed with
i i kind of understood the purpose of it
now i'm not really clear about what
we're actually
changing by passing this bill my
understanding is that uh
various citizens are concerned that they
that they will be mandated to have
certain uh particularly vaccinations as
a condition of employment
and that may very well be a violation of
uh the federal law it's enforced by the
equal employment opportunity commission
but in fact there's a rather high
barrier to appeal one's case to that
group if
we test this bill and the form that
would be where we could pass this
amendment then that would clearly be in
state law
and i think it would be much more
accessible to citizens than it would be
thank you
and let me add to that i do believe that
right to bodily integrity it's actually
implied in current law passing this
still makes it explicit
so i i i think in that sense it's an
improvement that i agree with you that
that may be less of a change than some
anyone else
mr chairman
uh yes
thank you
um
i think answer representative sebero's
comment
what i found with the amendment was it
provided clarity
over the original bill
so the original bill was kind of broad
but
using the amendment it sort of provides
the clarity that i was looking for
anyways
into what it really was meaning that was
intended to do
so
it
i support the amendment
um
on the surface because of providing that
clarity to it versus having something
representative shapiro is your hand uh
left over from last time or do you have
another
thing to bring to us
leftover
okay
well see
the vote is on
the amendment
zero five
seven five
moved by representative marsh
seconded by representative pushman would
[Music]
okay we'll try this again
representative
yes
still absent representative nelson
[Music]
i'll come back to representative acting
uh representative gay
yes representative cushman
yes
representative folsom yes representative
melvin you may not do that
no
um
[Laughter]
representative king
yes
representative kobalt yes
representative weber
yes
representative mckay
representative snow is still gone
representative knurk
yes
representative soloway
representative cannon
yes
representative nutter upham
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods
representative merchants
yes
okay thank you
um and representative pearson yes
okay that's 19 in the affirmative and
two absent
german consent
all
but it's a good try and hold that
thought
so now this becomes the bill and uh we
have a forest house bill 220
as amended by zero five seven five
and uh
it's a movement
representative marsh moves
and who is that
merchant
what's that
merch
righty um
um i will just say that i'm really
conflict conflicted about this bill on
the one hand i really appreciate all the
compromise that's gone into it and all
the thought that's gone into it on the
other hand i feel like um being in the
legislature has made me more a little
bit more of a libertarian
and um
kind of makes me feel like we don't have
to have a a
a law about everything and it seems like
at this point this is just a law that
we're passing
people feel okay about something that's
already in practice
so
[Music]
i guess i'm i have to decide whether to
thank you
representative weber
thank you mr chairman as you all know i
was fiercely opposed to the bill when as
it was originally drafted because i was
very concerned about the intersection of
every
possible unwanted medical intervention
and a
total non-discrimination clause
but i have to say that i am very much in
favor of the statement that people have
control over what
um
goes into their bodies and what medical
procedures they
uh wish to incur so
i think that having that statement
explicit
is perhaps a very good thing
and
given
the
points clarifications made in paragraph
two
i am now able to vote for the bill and i
the medical freedom statement is an
important statement that applies to so
many different areas of our
medical lives that
i will i will be voting in favor as the
as the bill is amended and i appreciate
the bill is house bill
220 as amended
zero five seven five h
marsh and seconded by representative
merchants
and the clerk please call the roll
thank you
representative marsh
yes
okay representative nelson
representative gay yes
representative cushman
yes
representative folsom yes representative
melvin yes
representative king
yes
representative kobalt
yes representative mckay
yes
representative snow is still gone uh
representative knurk
yes
representative soloway no
representative nutter uppam yes
yes
representative woods
representative merchant
yes representative pearson yes
okay 18
18 in the affirmative
one negative
and two absence would representative
soloway
wish us
not to put it on consent or you can put
it you can put it on consent thank you
and you representative marshall it's
already done
you already did it
all you need is a big printer right
there all right that
ends the exec on house bill 220.
now i open the executive session on
house bill 492
requiring maintenance of the cobit
dashboard
i was wondering if the sponsor of the
bill was going to come back to us with
amendments on amendment which might take
into account
things that we
discussed but
no amendments have been forthcoming at
least to me
representative marsh
yes thank you mr chairman uh i believe
that the department has done the best it
can and is continuing to improve the
covet 19 dashboard and i further
appealed that the
issue about
access to health care and
differences in uh outcomes amongst
various groups and seeing address by the
shopship commission and so therefore i
do not feel that there's need for an
additional commission and therefore i
would like to move itl and hospital
49ers
now i don't remember who did the first
thank you and also abby rogers from dhhs
said that she would talk with
representative schultz
about a few concerns
because the senate is working on
something similar to this and it might
well be addressed there and certainly
things that were raised in the hearing
um
i'm sure the dhhs took to heart because
they want to make things better so
anybody else
want to weigh in
on 492
representative gay
thank you
what's the proper thing to say that
we're discussing
stop thank you for taking my questions
can you just
thank you for taking my statement
anything you want okay
on page one
uh lines six through ten
vaccination information shall be
maintained in a way that allows for
cross-referencing of geographic location
age
race
that's just
sounds like there's going to be a name
attached so that that makes me uneasy
[Music]
i know that's aside from it being
duplicated
anyone
okay
the bill is house bill 492 requiring
maintenance of the cobit 19 dashboard
the motion is itl
made by representative marsh and
seconded by
me representative pearson and would the
thank you
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon is still absent
representative nelson
yes
representative acton
thank you representative gay yes
representative cushman
yes
representative folsom yes representative
melvin yes
representative king
yes
representative cofoult
representative weber
yes
representative mckay
representative snow is he back no
um representative knurk
yes
representative soloway yes
representative cannon
yes
representative nutter upham
yes representative shapiro
yes
representative woods
representative merchants
yes
and representative pearson
yes and it is 19 in the affirmative two
absence
it goes
it's closed
on hospital 4 92
and
[Music]
i now open the exec session on house
bill
157 footnotes
fn financial note
and there is an amendment in front of me
[Music]
author the prime author is
representative marsh with good help from
representatives edwards representative
marsh would you wish to speak to the
amendment yes thank you mr chairman
first of all i wish to thank senator
sherman who provided the staff to
basically
create what
was not something but it might as well
have been one that enabled us to come up
with this amendment because he did not
have the staff
to do and i truly appreciate that
because i believe that we've reached
some traits and senses here
zero four eight eight h uh and she will
call the additional bill
bill
and he determined that the reason behind
that was that certain people felt
disenfranchised by the charge and the
membership on the shopship commission
and with the help of
senator sherman and representative
edwards
sponsored
and the membership of the commission uh
in such a way that really everyone feels
satisfied including the shawshank
any questions for representative marsh
representative folsom oh thank you mr
chair my question is more for you if
we're speaking to the amendment should a
i'm sorry what i believe i moved
amendment zero four eighty eight eight
if i didn't i apologize and i'll make
that relationship
thank you
yeah representative thank you
point of order
yes
uh sorry uh
representative marsh
which amendment did you just move
zero four eight eight it's the one with
your name on but wait a minute what
about zero five seven six the one you
just sent out to fix the hospital issue
oh you're right i'm sorry it's a good
figure i just called jerry mr chairman
i'm awake
you
built
and the correct number zero four eight
eight
and if you look down at the amendment
i'll tell you the line number where we
fix the hospital's issue
i'm sorry i had a clip to the wrong bill
my
herb mr chairman could i
inquire
yes please uh when was that amendment
sent out
uh
about a week or two weeks ago the date
on its february i've lost all control
over my amendments so
um i thank you that will help me find it
the date is february 23rd on it
okay
[Music]
which is the amendment that i moved
initially
is correct so let me reiterate i am
moving adoption of amendment zero four
eight eight h and i'm going to ask
representative kenner if he would like
to second that
yes i would and i'd like to apologize
for having clipped the wrong amendment
to the wrong bill i lost all control as
well my apology
representative we take turns in doing
that representative weber had one last
week and i've met several and somebody
else's turn is coming up soon so not the
one i just remembered we had a new
amendment want to make sure we had the
proper one and he did have the proper
we could weigh the pounds
[Music]
any further discussion on the amendment
that being zero four eight eight h
yes um representative cushman thank you
mr chairman
representative march does this bill have
anything on it
um
we had discussed that there would be an
amendment to incorporate in some of the
things that were on um
i can't remember the number it was max
abramson's bill and we
um
we itled it
controlling healthcare costs
and
incorporating
exploration of free market
principles and improving health care
the answer to your question is yes uh
page one lines twelve to fourteen
cost of health care insurance coverage
uh
health care's insurance coverage is
taught is on as representative kenork
said on line 17
uh but that's not the major reference
the major references on page two line
three
where we
want to reduce the cost both to
individuals and overall in the health
care system yeah that's important
because
with cost shifting cost individuals may
not be reduced when we are not reducing
the cost of the health care system and
the last has to do with uh
membership on the commission uh where
the the uh josiah martin member we
anticipate
the freelance healthcare solution so i
believe that we have uh addressed those
concerns so that those people have a
voice at the table
and see
your faces because if we're looking at
the good amendment
representative snow has his hand up
i just wanted to report that i had to go
down to get my shot and i'm back
we're on 157 right we are yes
mr chairman
yes
if i could ask again representative
marsh or
kanark to go over
the changes between this amendment
and the one before which i think was
amendment
zero two seven zero
yes i'll be glad to do that
representative
the
only change between those two amendments
is that
in the prior amendment there were two uh
representatives from hospitals number
two and an additional representative of
the hospital added later on in the
amendment in this amendment as you can
see on page 3 uh lines 16 through 18 we
have amalgamated the three
representatives of some hospitals the
new one that's being added to the
commission
is a uh
one from an academic medical center
anybody else
but i think there we go
i don't see
yeah mr chairman
yes representative for clarity so
basically if i understand this correctly
representative marsh we just took the
word large health care system
in an asserted academic medical center
uh that was a recommendation of from the
shaw ship commission when the amendment
the fire event was discussed at the
commission they thought that that was
clearer and i agree
i agree
thank you
just a question
uh representative gay oh what is
an academic medical center is that like
a
school it's a teaching hospital
okay
like dartmouth yes
but it does not have to have a medical
school attached correct it could have
interns and residents
yes representative melvin mr chairman
could i be excused i don't have any of
so if i don't feel confident
this is
this is the amendment that is in
question
representative solo i'd love you to
recognize representatives
president i recognize
uh thank you mr assistant chair or i
have been admonished to refer to you as
mr chairman as you are now in that role
just for the information of the
committee
once upon a time when one said academic
medical center in the state of new
hampshire one meant quite explicitly
dartmouth hitchcock and only dartmouth
hitchcock that has now changed and there
are at least two academic medical
centers in the state portsmouth regional
hospital is now a teaching hospital for
tufts medical school
thank you representative i was aware of
that fact that perhaps others were not
of representative snow is your hand
still up or did you mean to lower no
i'll take it down
are there any other questions about the
amendment
mr chairman would you like me to ask the
clerk to call the world because there
are no further questions i would like to
give representative milton about another
30 seconds
but someone please ask another question
if you're looking for filler i've got
something um
so we should pass if we should adopt
this amendment
and um
what is the what is the major thrust of
this bill that we're passing what will
we be
doing with the amendment
well as you recall
the original bill was would have
repealed this commission and that's
certain members and i believe those are
the members that
represent the
asked us about earlier did not feel that
they had a seat at the table in
developing the state health assessment
state health improvement plan uh what
this amendment does is it uh recognizes
the fact that we need to to incorporate
the input of all concerned uh citizens
and interested parties in developing
this plan and it was the consensus of
the group and of the commission that
this addressed the concerns and
therefore we do not need to reveal the
commission but we will instead modify
the commission slightly so that
else
and we are voting on amendments
zero four eight eight to house bill 157
moved by representative marsh seconded
by representative kenner with the clerk
please call the world
thank you
representative marsh votes yes
is he better no more than happy now i
don't see him okay um representative
nelson
yes
representative acton
representative gay
yes
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
melvin yes
representative king yes
representative kobalt
yes
representative weber yes
representative mckay
yes
representative snow
representative knurk
yes
representative soloway yes
representative cannon thanks yes sorry
thank you
representative nutter upham yes
representative woods
uh yes
representative merchant
yes
you skipped
did i
yes
yes and yes i'm sorry
i am sorry
okay sorry
um
i recognize representative marsh for
further motion mr chairman i move
hospital 157 octopass as amended with
i concur with representative marsh
since i'm back in my seat and i don't
have to kill any time one last shot for
we are now voting on
house bill 157 fn as amended by
0488h moved by representative marsh
seconded by representative merchants
and with the clerks paying special
attention to our dear friend
representative shapiro call the rule
thank you i sure will uh representative
marsh
yes
representative mcmahon absent
representative nelson yes yes
yes
thank you representative gay
representative cushman
yes
representative folsom yes representative
melvin
yes representative king
yes
representative cofolt
representative weber
yes
representative mckay
representative snow
yes
representative knurk
representative soloway
yes
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes
representative pearson
20 in the affirmative and one absence
and the objection to consent
and i'm going to expect that uh the
weather's not written yeah of course it
is
all right now uh opening the exact
session on house bill 131
relative to reporting of health care
associated
infections and that is representative
woods
thank you mr chair
excuse me
this was a fairly straightforward bill
there were a couple of questions um
from some representatives which
i tried to uh discuss with and i'm i'm
sure i've answered their questions but
left it open
to see if they wanted any amendments uh
none were forthcoming
uh so the bill stands as as it was um
presented
i'd like to make a motion
i would like to make a motion that we
pass house bill 131
off to pass
whose
okay
yes mr chair
representative marsh i believe that
there was some discussion earlier about
the word measures in this bill i believe
that we made clear that that is
something that is uh from the
centers for medicaid services on the
federal level and is
pretty much
going to be a part of this process
i couldn't catch all of that but yes the
measures were inserted
at the request of dhhs
that makes it consistent with reporting
activities that they do
um
the
different agencies that are are listed
um
in section three
uh uh are not uh mandatory uh um uh
guideline are not mandatory uh
uh rules that they have to follow but
guidelines uh and standards that they
can uh check to see how they're doing
when they look at facilities um
the
term measures was added because that is
the term that's often used uh in
reviewing sites uh that the uh these uh
um
the only other uh question that came up
uh was relative to line six about
again emphasizing that
i think the concern was
these might be mandated these are not
mandated
these are survey
measures only
so that we can as a state keep ourselves
posted as to what the status of new
hampshire is relative to the various
vaccines from school childhood vaccines
to adult vaccines so that we can then
identify not mandate but identify the
status of the state in terms of its
current
vaccination levels
this is important for a variety of
reasons i'll just use one example
if we don't have that data and we don't
know what kind of vaccinations are
occurring in schools
uh as you know there was a measles
outbreak um but that could occur without
even knowing about it
mumps is one as well and i've personal
experience with that
uh that if we don't know
what the vaccination levels are and
mumps does occur
it can occur and then bring it home
and unbeknownst
so we need to keep monitoring it uh the
difficulty is it's not just the kids if
you bring it home and adults get it
and uh adults as you some people
probably know adults that get mumps it's
a can be very devastating
and women and my mother i brought it
home and my mother got the mumps she
almost had to have a tracheostomy so she
could breathe
uh men if they get in an adulthood are
frequently sterile
as a consequence
it's very important for us to know not
just for the kids but for adults uh so
the consequences
of just it's it's a level
of awareness that we can uh give
our
constituents in the states of new
hampshire knowing that
what
how we stand relative to any particular
disease
yes uh representative gay
thank you for thank you for granting and
thank you for answering my question
i
understand about the measles and the
monks but i'm not seeing what lines are
pretending pertaining to those i'm just
seeing on line six
the mention of influenza and lines 24.
yes that's i'm just using that as an
example
there's other
this is for reporting purposes excuse me
excuse me
it says hospital shall also initially
identify track and report
that doesn't mean other things aren't
surveyed just like in lines four and
five
uh those are right uh picc lines are are
internal lines that had to be reported
um
now the the uh compliance level is about
95 to 98 percent level
so
no longer do the facilities that use
those kinds of internal lines have to
provide a report
when the site is reviewed they're still
reviewed
but they don't have to report
because they're
working at a high level of compliance
and the same way with other vaccines as
well
so
representative weber
and just going back to circling around
to the very beginning on this am i not
correct that the
the big thrust of this bill was to
relieve hospitals of having to report
uh information that we all agree
is not necessary anymore because the um
things that they're reporting are such
standard procedure that we just it's
um counterproductive for them to have to
assemble the information and send it in
regularly is that correct yes that's
correct that's what i mean they were at
such a compliance that they no longer
have to they're still have to perform
that and they're reviewed on that
but this relieves them from the uh
representative snow
yes
probably i'm the only one that doesn't
understand this but i see no mention in
this bill of covid 19 vaccination is
that just assumed that that would also
be
tracked
um i can't
excuse me i can't say that that's nearly
tracked under a different
uh guy's um and uh representative marsh
yes i'd like to answer the question that
this bill is aimed at the national
quality uh improvement initiative
hospitals
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman so i'm just going to make
comments that i had made the last time
we talked about this bill
um that i believe that this term
measures is
um to allow tracking and reporting um
including
other vaccinations in healthcare
personnel patients and residents
in healthcare facilities this measures
language is new and
it's intended to
include vaccinations as an infection
control measure
um and i don't agree with doing this it
opens the door to
um pressure coming from
the the
from the top of the hierarchy in these
facilities all the way down because now
we're tracking now we're going to make
it happen and your argument that
we do away with reporting pick lines
kind of
bolsters that thought for me that
you know this is to
increase
whatever they're measuring
until they have compliance and no longer
have to measure it anymore
um
i don't see a demonstrated need for
such such broad language
and i
i
i don't i haven't heard of any
healthcare associated communicable
disease outbreaks that weren't this
tracking and i i
wanted a an amendment to make it clear
that this these reporting and tracking
of measures
does not include anything but uh vax any
vaccinations but those explicitly
outlined in this statute
um
but we didn't come to that agreement and
that is all thank you
thank you
thank you um um
that's one interpretation for the use of
measures but um
a dhhs is i think uh listening in
and they might be able to provide for
information purposes a very explicit
detailed uh
concept of exactly
what the term measures means
and uh um it's its implementation
um and that may clarify that
and
i apologize to katrina because
our schedule went way wacky off of what
i had promised her so i hope she's
not given up on us but if there is
somebody from dhhs we occasionally in an
exact session calling an expert witness
for clarification is there someone from
dhhs abby rogers or katrina or john
williams or somebody who could address
that question
um
katrina katrina was going to be
listening in but
[Music]
okay
hello everyone my name is katrina hanson
can you please hear me or can you hear
me members of the community again
apologies for the time going all wacky
i appreciate it thank you no it's okay
um i was able to um coordinate and um
work with abby rogers to sign off and
back on so also thank her
um so yes thank you for your question
representative cushman and others um
this term measures is to allow us to
provide um kind of
near real-time changes if we needed to
but we'd have to go through our whole
administrative rules process so i do
want to clarify if there is a change to
any process or outcome measures for
hai reporting or healthcare associated
infections we'd still have to go through
an administrative rules process
in regards to the the question about
vaccine
and healthcare personnel flu influenza
vaccination tracking
currently and what we continue to do and
what we plan to continue to do is to
continue to track it
by healthcare setting
including hospitals long-term care
facilities and other facilities
for health care workers and residents or
patients
we use this information and can be very
valuable because we do see a range of
experience we do see
outbreaks of influenza
during typical influenza seasons
primarily impacted or primarily at
facilities that may have lower
vaccination
rates among health care workers so at
times that can be very helpful for us to
understand and be able to provide
recommendations and guidance to those
health care facilities
what we have seen is health hospital
settings tend to have
they've had high
rates um since we've been tracking the
data
more recently but in the very beginning
it was actually lower and has changed
over time
we continue to see
lower vaccination within healthcare
personnel in populations in other
settings such as in long-term care
assisted living nursing homes so i do
want to mention that
for other process measures
right now
we don't plan to add any process
measures but we may have a need at in if
if there is a change
or new antibiotic-resistant organism for
example so
right now we are tracking certain
measures and you can see that here but
it's very possible we may see a new
antibiotic-resistant organism or as
often called a superbug and we need to
adapt modify our administrative rules to
be able to track those within the
surveillance system that is available
for healthcare associated infections so
that's why the term measures is there um
and i hope i address the questions
but i'm willing to answer any other
questions or
no hands thank you so much
you're welcome thank you for having me
anyone else wish to speak
house bill 131 relative to reporting of
healthcare-associated
infections
moved by representative woods
seconded by representative marsh would
yes thank you
representative nelson
yes
did we lose him
not
uh
um oh
a thumbs up okay i'll take that okay
representative gay
yes
representative cushman
no
representative folsom yes
representative
oates
let's switch them on the sheet melvin
yeah
representative king
no
representative kofolt
representative weber
yes
representative mckay
representative snow
yes
representative knurk
yes representative salloway
yes
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods
representative merchant
yes
17 in the affirmative three negative and
one absent
and representative woods would you write
the committee report please for the
majority
of amongst the three who voted no would
like to do the minority
report
representative cushman does
this closes the exec session on house
bill 131 and this opens the exec session
on house bill 605
and first we have before us an amendment
by representative canark
number zero five one eight h
and representative canaric would you
speak to your amendments
or would you actually make a motion
yes i would like to move amendment zero
is there
no not yet is there a second yes
second did that
who who's that
carol
would you repeat that number again
please
zero five one eight
eight
and who was the second
merchant
and representative connect you may speak
to your amendment
yes thank you as you recall this was a
bit of a house omnibus bill
uh wrapping up a whole bunch of bills
that went through last year uh through
the house but never got through the
cove pandemic
um but it had a lot of redundancy with
other uh issues that we have either
already passed or um we're moving ahead
on or in other ways
so for example insomnia we already
passed out as a as hb 89
uh the information about pregnancy we
passed a much more robust bill uh with
163 repealing the therapeutic cannabis
advisory council we already passed that
out um so what we ended up doing was
basically getting rid of a lot oh sorry
and the first two sections as enumerated
on the analysis are already in sb 162
they're requested by dhhs and so that's
already running through the senate so to
tidy this up and make it a lot less
cumbersome
we basically cut it down to being just
the issue about um a redefinition of
in the very first section if you look in
lines five through eight just simply
adding that issue about um
the designated caregivers and visiting
qualifying patients um
then we have the issue about cannabis
for therapeutic purposes
uh that is sections 9
through 17. and that is with the
rather rigid stipulations from the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board and the remaining portion of it
just tidies up some issues about
out-of-state residents being able to
access
therapeutic cannabis at one of our
atc's
now just to go back though to make this
just a little bit clearer i do still
want to report
that the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board did not vote
overwhelmingly for adding opioid use
disorder many of the other things you
heard me speak about we did vote like
you know nine to zero or eight to one or
whatever we were split on this
um and we did not go back to revisit it
we'd had a few absences that day
and the vote ended up being four to six
i.e it failed when we talked about
whether we should add oud and that is
because of some of the unique
considerations but likewise because we
did recognize that
the um this is in 2019 retained bill
that the house may not follow that
recommendation because we were rather
split
we did work very hard to come up with a
number of restrictions so that if it did
pass it could be acceptable and indeed
even after
we uh
even after this uh was passed through as
uh 366 last uh
well it was a 2019 bill that got acted
on at 20. um
we even went back and just made sure to
tidy up the language to add that issue
about for the individual patient for the
person doing medication assisted
treatment so
it's not like the therapeutic cannabis
medical advisory board thought this was
a ghastly idea and should never be done
but they did not give it any kind of
overwhelming support by any means i
think it was the type of thing with this
that if we're going to do it
put all these restrictions in so that it
is
a high bar for a person to get to so
we're sure that people aren't giving uh
people with oud a bunch of thc which
would be counterproductive but instead
would know that they want to be going
with primarily cbd which does have good
evidence that it can be helpful
so that was the part that is actually
controversial about this bill um
but again we did pass it through the
house last year because we felt it would
be a reasonable addition with the
representative marsh
thank you mr chair i
unfortunately cannot support this
amendment for two reasons
first of all as representative testified
to us the uh
scientific evidence on the use of
cannabis for opiate
use disorder is at best equipable and
at least six members of the advisory
panel did not recommend adding that
indication at this time
um the second reason is that the
language about people from other states
and countries being able to access our
alternative care centers i think is
somewhat problematic i i could see
language that would allow other states i
could even see language that are not in
canada accessing our alternative
treatment centers but the current
language that about anyone from any
country anywhere in the world
someone with laws are
at best obscure uh and and i think that
that's too broad and i cannot support it
so i will be voting against this man
may i respond
you may respond
okay uh well it's not anybody from
anywhere can access it's only a person
who is does have a valid uh registration
card or it's equivalent and part of this
is to take care of the situation where
we may have out of state students who
are in our state or other people who are
milit uh well probably not military but
other people who may be stationed here
for a job
and are a therapeutic cannabis patient
let's say in maine
they would have the choice of either
purchasing in maine and then
transporting across a state line which
is illegal
or to be able to purchase here which
we thought would be a preferable way to
handle that
as long as they have a valid
registration card
i really don't think we have many other
countries that are doing this because
that's not the situation
i can appreciate your concern about that
and michael may be on this
i didn't check to see and he may have a
reason why the department requested
that that piece would be in there
i do not see him on the attendee list
though
thank you representative i didn't say
that i was opposed to the idea i said i
got it
thank you mr chairman i think that
looking at the amendment um
i understand representative marsha's
concerns but i have to say that i think
under the very
um
limited
uh
circumstances under which opioid use
disorder can be addressed
um
and
i i i'm i'm okay going with that um
and then the other thing is um with
respect to say a foreign national who
comes
you know there was a time when we had a
really vibrant
tourist industry in this state and i
hope to have one again actually i think
it's going to be pretty vibrant this
year but it'll just be from local places
rather than farther afield but i think
for something that has
turned out to be
very helpful for a great number of
citizens and has allowed them
to enhance the quality of their lives
rather than diminish the quality of
their lives um i'm i'm going to vote in
of the amendment um and then in favor of
the bill i think the amendment enhances
the bill because we don't want to have
all those other
pieces of the bill running around and i
think that as drafted
i'm i can support this and uh appreciate
the effort that went into it thank you
representative folsom
um thank you mr chair i i
as i'm looking at this section um
five with um the valid registry
identification card or it's equivalent
i think with the way that this is
written
with uh people coming from
could come from a large variety of
personnel to be able to judge whether or
not the card is real
are they going to have to have a book
with
what the cards look like from each state
or from each country or province or
territory
so that they know how that it's actually
really
an id card and not just
some card made up to look like a
professional id card
so i struggle with that because all of a
sudden we're putting that decision
everyone else
representative gay
i also feel uncomfortable
about two and three and the uh amendment
for the reasons that our clerk just
stated
and um
i'm also thinking that if you're using
cannabis for
treatment you know exactly which kinds
you've tried that work
if you're coming on a vacation
i don't mean you but people
um if going on vacation or traveling
whatever medication i take i take it
with me i don't count on finding it
and um so i'm not real concerned about
somebody visiting here and producing a
card and
shopping
for their cannabis
for medical reasons
um
and i also like to
not feel real comfortable until treating
an opioid
you take too much
i'd like to see a lot more research on
giving them
another
well marijuana
to be specific as a cure it sounds like
swapping what you're dependent upon
representative connor can you answer
that if you wish
yes um i mean the problem with bringing
your own medications is that this is a
drug
uh therapeutic cannabis is illegal to
cross state lines or to enter into the
united states with so it's not something
that like your prescription for the
center probe which you can just take
with you when you travel so that's why
we always have to do all these
contortions to deal with the fact that
it's federally illegal
but it is allowable in the state in a
therapeutic fashion
um with regard to the other piece um the
goal here is not just to say oh go use
cannabis for treating oud and that's why
this very high bar of it needing to be a
person who's already qualified to do
medication-assisted treatment that would
be like suboxone
where a bit for that particular patient
or
a addictions uh medicine or addiction
psychiatry physician so these are
individuals who will know what they're
doing and would be
trying to use a mix of
medications they may use suboxone but
they also may add some
cbd rich
cannabis to decrease the the cravings
and the withdrawal symptoms because
that's where we do have some evidence
that it can be helpful
and that's why we said in these
why the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board even though we sort of overall
never voted to go for it did continue to
work on it even afterward to continue to
put enough restrictions in that we felt
it would be workable and it probably
would have been better if we had just
revoked it some time but we never
actually
did a revote on it we just kept tweaking
it because it was a sort of a fade.com
plea after it got passed last year and
we added this further language so it
went to the senate it could be amended
to be even better
so
i you know i agree that there are
concerns that's why i brought it up for
discussion because it was not a slam
dunk like insomnia was or
asd
but it was something which
um
you know there are pretty high bars that
we've put in here to try to make it only
from people who know what they're doing
not just your primary care doc that
certifies you to go use cannabis to
anyone else
i see representative merchants
thank you mr chairman
and
thank you for taking my question
representative
i want to follow up on the issue about
crossing state lines
we want people to come to new hampshire
from outside the state so they can spend
their money
and be here
and i think one of the things that we
have as a barrier sometimes is that
we don't
allow for people who are on cannabis
medically
to obtain it here so puts them in a
quandary between do i go to new
hampshire and take the chance of getting
arrested
across state lines to take a plane
or do i land in manchester
and be able to go to dispensary and buy
the product
we have a lot of reciprocal agreements
between our states including driver's
license marriage license and so forth
this is my opinion just another
extension of that
reciprocity that we enjoy amongst the
states that we honor the other state's
requirements for getting a license or in
this case getting a
permit card to buy the cannabis so i
support the amendment i also support the
bill i want to say first and foremost
though to represent connect
thank you for taking an eight or nine
page document and getting it down to
three pages that in itself was an
accomplishment
well my cold helped me a lot we worked
together
and by the way i should say i have
texted mike hold and asked him if he
could join in to ask answer some of
those questions he's not yet responded i
wish i could get him in because he would
be able to give some of the reasons
because that was a department request to
have that in
um
i mean it was
yeah
i do see that abigail rogers has raised
her hand
hi members of the committee this is abby
rogers i'm the legislative liaison for
the department um thank you very much
for letting me speak i uh also reached
out to mike holt to hope hopefully that
he could join because he has uh the best
information on some of your questions
related to therapy to canvas and this
proposed legislation um but in lieu of
him being there i can try to answer some
questions for you or also take questions
back for mike whatever would be most
thank you um so am i right in thinking
that that the language that we were
talking about about residency was in
fact a request of the department
um that i'm not sure on on that
particular provision um
uh i know that uh representative knurk
and representative and mike had been
working closely together on the language
that was my recollection but i cannot be
100 certain
um i know sections one and two of the
original bill
were requested by dhhs
i may be incorrect
about the out of state being requested
my apologies for not having that with
certainty i've also just called michael
left a message
right i'm sorry i i'm not able to uh
give you a clear answer on whether we
have requested
if we had one it might have been helpful
anyone else with a question for abby
rogers
i see
representative folsom your hand is up
oh
no i think i just forgot to take it down
sorry
representative merchants
i forgot to take it down
anyone else
wish to speak
to amendment zero five one
eight
h as moved by representative canarcon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative knurk can you speak um to
the
um
part of the original bill that was about
the cultivation of marijuana now has
that been
is that been stripped from this
amendment
yes but we also passed that bill too i'm
blanking now on the number
um
that was one i think that representative
acton brought in so he should be able to
throw that number at us
okay but it's still referred to under um
online hp 350.19.
[Music]
18 and 19.
page one
um
curses let's see
yeah that was hp 350. if you guys can
hear me
yes we can okay thanks
actually but sorry but that that again
comes in as a visiting qualifying
patient piece
um
so that a visiting qualifying patient uh
would be able to purchase
from
a qualifying patient or designated
caregiver
so does that
excuse me follow-up
oh
does that infer that a visiting
person with a card could cultivate
that is a good question which again i do
not know i relied too much on mike holt
on
i'm trying to just quickly pull up the
i'm sorry i didn't hear that
uh representative weber i had a quick
point of procedure
sure
i'm i'm wondering if
it
it sounds to me like there are a couple
of definite
concerns here
one of which is the
um issue of opioid use disorder
which is problematical for some people
a second one of which is uh
at at a minimum
the
inclusion of people from outside the
united states
in the
um
population and then the third thing is
the
uh interpretation of 18 and 19 which is
a matter of looking back at the rest of
the statute that exists and seeing how
it changes it
and i'm wondering if it might be a good
idea at this point to recess the
executive session on this bill till the
next week
so that some of those things could be
explored and perhaps
um an amendment or two in the
alternative prepared so that um
we could
achieve some kind of consensus about
those things that the committee is
really clear on and and and strip out
some of the things or or give a choice
on some of the things that the committee
is less clear on
would definitely matter to
representatives
yes actually that's very much what i was
beginning to think about is listening to
the conversation as it evolves and and
coming up with that i should also
quickly report that i was able to find
this uh
the uh the lines that represent shapiro
brought up lines 18 and 19. it is those
are exceptions in other words
therapeutic use means everything but
does not include so it does not include
cultivation or purchase by so no it does
not allow cultivation it it explicitly
says you can't cultivate it's one of the
things that are not included so my
apologies i'm not having that clear
so i think that part's easy but i think
you're right we have
the
oud as a separate thing and i could
certainly come up with an amendment that
did not include the oud
um i would also say that tcmob is
meeting this wednesday tomorrow
and we perhaps i might have them revisit
this with our current language and see
what their current status is on this i
think that would be very wise i can add
that to the agenda and i'll have that
answer by next monday
and then the last thing is that issue
about
the other countries and i can certainly
check with mike as to how important that
is and perhaps that could be amended out
to
make uh
representative marsh and some others a
little bit more comfortable about that
issue i would think across the state
lines we still have a reason because
when
michael
testified he did clearly point out this
issue of visiting people students people
who have a second home and come over and
stay for an extended period of time and
it's for that group of people as
representative merchant alluded to that
we want to be able to have that
reciprocity but reciprocity frequently
goes across states doesn't necessarily
go across country lines
so
would you be willing to withdraw your
amendment and representative
your second
i'll yes i'll be willing to do that and
then i'll bring it back with
some some work on it after we meet on
wednesday and have a fresh one for you
uh
i'll put it in the folder for next
monday and shoot it out to us as soon as
you can
so um
you have withdrawn your motion in
representative merchant your second um
uh representative folsom i think do you
have a clerky question uh no uh just a
statement
a regular statement yeah as opposed to a
clerky question as opposed to a clerky
okay thank you um representative as
you're working on this um
if i i can say this much about for
myself if you take out the
outside of the united states i'd feel a
whole lot more comfortable with that
portion
and um
the
uh
when it comes to the opioid i would
i would like you to get an input from
your board
because that's uh you know they've
provided us with good information before
and
the information that we have from the
previous vote that you told us about
makes it very iffy for me
um and so
uh that i would have to hear a more
positive
uh response from that group and then i
feel much more comfortable about it but
my main thing is not from outside the
states
thank you for that
and that's again why when i presented
this amendment i brought up the
controversy about this because i wanted
people to know that this was not the
kind of thing where we did have
agreement and it was striking when i
brought this back as hp 366 back in the
fall of 19 that our subcommittee said
yeah let's do it and they you know they
wanted the restrictions and then we
brought it back to the full committee
and they voted to go ahead with it and
as i say the tcmob wasn't wasn't like
astounded or terribly upset about it
they had just just worked on the
language a bit more so it is possible
and also with the difference in
attendance at different meetings we
might actually approve but i think that
would feel make all of us feel more
comfortable because that was the goal so
i'd be glad to do this over this next
two days
and have something ready for you or
perhaps
a couple of amendments ready that we
could then figure out which one will
work best for this group
so just to make sure i'm not missing
anything
oud was one concern
other countries clearly a concern
uh representative cushman's concern
about the atc's need to know what
foreign cards look like gets us back to
that uh other countries type question
and i think
jerry
um
while we're helping him rewrite bell
uh to make it as possible for as many of
us as possible to vote for um let him
know if there's any other sticky spots
because
please let me know today
yeah yeah i hate to come in and and i
mean we do a great job here
yeah sometimes
and i that's a that's a good thing about
this committee so let's hope on this
representative weber
um i'm sorry i i had not yet lowered my
hand from my last go-round so
oh sorry
hey i what and last comment i i do
appreciate this again this was not my
bill and so it was a kind of a salvage
issue and i know we don't rewrite this
but it was really a matter of just
getting rid of a lot of dead wood and
then getting down to the nitty-gritty
which was
still some nitty-gritty so i will work
on it thank you
for all right
we get it representative gay thank you
um
you mentioned something about reciprocal
agreements between states
the bill doesn't say that but that
sounds much more appealing to me
than saying
somebody can just come with quote a
valid registry id card
from another state
how much how
how in sam hill would you know it was
any good if you didn't have a reciprocal
arrangement with that other state that
that would be
a deal breaker for me
and i'm
personally i'm not
thrilled i'm still not thrilled with
roman numeral
adds opioid use disorder i'm not
comfortable with that but i am
comfortable
if you restrict the interstate to
states that have an agreement with each
other
anyone
else uh could i just comment i'm not
quite sure
given the fact that we still are dealing
with an interstate uh
illegal substance i'm not sure how well
we can do true reciprocity issues but i
will discuss that with michael thank you
i meant the cards recep reciprocity
between the iv
representative folsom a new hand yeah a
new hand thank you um and i'll remember
to take this one down
um
just a thought here
getting rid of all the other countries
it is a lot easier
to have a little handout for the atc
clerks with the with the states that
have a medical marijuana card they could
have a printout and
it's not going to be as cumbersome as
trying to come up with ones from other
countries
um so that's that's going to be a little
bit easier um
and and i i have to tell you that
most of
um
most of the marijuana coming uh from
that group is coming across state lines
and they probably aren't going to use
the um atc's anyway
so for the most part the people going
into the atc's are going to be people
with the medical marijuana card if
they're from the states i feel
comfortable with that
um the rest is going to come in
regardless
you get just a few more minutes before
some of us turn pumpkins yeah so any
last minute
comments and if you think of one on the
way home
you should have representative connect
representative nelson thank you
thank you what about the state thank you
mr chairman what about this states that
it's totally legal is it in colorado or
someplace anybody can go in and buy it
what happens if they come that they
don't need a card do they
yeah
if they wish to buy it in an atc yes
they need a card if you wish to buy it
in the black market they're welcome to
do whatever they wish because it's not
legal in this state
how about their own state
they can buy it in colorado you can buy
at a uh
non-dispensary anywhere for recreational
but it's
still illegal it's still illegal to
bring it into another state
seeing no further hands up and not
really just
to clarify so
in colorado you can have one of two
different things you can still have a
card in colorado uh so you would have
the card in colorado to bring here
because your color colorado card
entitles you to a different tax
structure than your
uh recreational use so it's not that
they don't have a card they have a card
and they could bring the card and
without the card they can't just say hey
it's legal in colorado so you have to
give me
therapeutic marijuana they have to have
a card
and i think that that's the case for
most of the other states too
thank you and with that i'm going to
bring this hearing this exact session
whatever this is exact session on hp 605
to a close on monday the 8th of march
we will be
looking for the first time at bill 506
103.
now i've got a bit of a confusion here
one of my notes say that we finished
the hearing on 601.
another note says that we didn't and it
can't be both so what is your
recollection on 601 what was the title
of 601
oh
that's our 601 um
the private personal information
retained by a health or social service
agency of prohibiting the sharing
thereof we have not exact 601 another i
thought
i thought we hadn't finished the hearing
on that one
but
if 602 was the it was either 601 or 602
but i don't i don't think it was both
602 is definitely we have to continue
then i listed it wrong in the um house
journal
i listed 601 as continued public hearing
and they even typed it wrong so
maybe it washes out um
we will also
exact
146 and i think
that will take care of everything
so my suggestion is
be prepared i'm holding
the next
that thursday the 11th
and we can only do execs on it because
i i have nothing to put into the journal
but execs can be helped
so i hope to get done
monday yeah what you're snoring oh yeah
with respect to procedure i'm a little
confused
um
if if we have a continued hearing
that has i think that has to go into the
calendar so if it's gotten in wrong we
need to fix it
that's item number one
let me let me address that before item
number next
um since this is on monday the calendar
that has been printed is the last
calendar that will give legal notice for
monday
and what i have is continued on 602
continued on 103 but i put in continued
public hearing on 601. that was a
mistake
i just urge you then to consult with the
clerk about that
what i did in the past and it seemed to
have passed muster
was once you have noticed all of the
executive sessions
and however much i object to it you have
already noticed all of them because
you've said that anything that's ready
for executive session can be exact
i i think the thing to do is to
simply notice for the thursday is
continued executive session if needed
and certainly i i did that regularly
last time
when it was unclear to me whether we
were going to get through our work or
not get through our work i mean you
can't tell before the calendar is
published
thank you for that that's very helpful
so i hope that that's of of assistance
but you know continuing
executive session on all remaining bills
i think is
um
given that we're accepting that kind of
notice i mean it's a lot easier to
figure out what hasn't been done at that
point sure
any other questions about monday
schedule going forward yes okay six
everyone's the hearing i've already
closed our time together so
i just thought we were going to get
another